Instacart lets you get groceries just the way you like
with no markups at select retailers.
Now that's a win-win.
A win-win that can snowball into more wins.
So sink into the big chair, recline all the way back.
And hey, while you're at it, finish the crossword you've been putting off.
The hard one.
Do it in pen.
Instacart 让你能以自己喜欢的方式购买杂货，且在指定零售商处无加价。这真是双赢。这种双赢还能像滚雪球一样带来更多赢面。所以，陷进那张大椅子里，把椅背完全放倒。嘿，顺便说一句，把那份你一直拖着没做的填字游戏完成吧。就是那份难的。用钢笔填。
If you get it wrong, so what?
Instacard is helping deliver the groceries you want right to your door.
So no matter what, you're already a winner.
Want no markups just how you like?
Download the Instacard app today.
Fees and in-store off exclusions apply.
Hello and welcome to our second drink of Blood Drive.
In this episode, we get to hear from Katie Azleton, who played the adorable gal in the Bloodmobile with Michael.
如果填错了又怎样？Instacart 正在帮你把你想要的杂货送到家门口。所以无论如何，你已经是赢家了。想要无加价且完全符合你心意的服务吗？今天就下载 Instacart 应用程序吧。费用和店内排除条款适用。你好，欢迎收看我们第二杯“献血活动”。在这一集中，我们将听到 Katie Azleton 的分享，她在剧中饰演了与 Michael 一起在献血车里的那个可爱女孩。
And we got some really great behind-the-scenes tidbits from producer Randy Cordray.
All right.
Well, let's start with this question from Romano H from Northridge, California.
Hi, Angela and Jenna.
I was watching the superfan version of Blood Drive, and Phyllis talks about how she won't let Bob send her flowers to work on Valentine's Day.
It was so funny. Were there any alts for it? Okay. First of all, don't you just love that people like, Jenna, they just know the language of the show. They're like, were there alts? Yes. They know candy bag. All of it. You started background catch, which we get in letters. I love it. I love it too. Well, Romano, thank you so much for writing in. You know, I hadn't seen the superfan version of this episode. But after reading your question, I went and watched this talking head specifically. It's super funny. And I actually. I actually.
actually want to hear it and then we're going to discuss. Okay. I learned my lesson years ago. No
flowers on Valentine's Day. This place is full of player haters. Oh my gosh. It's so funny because,
我们还从制片人 Randy Cordray 那里得到了一些非常棒的幕后花絮。好了，让我们从加州北岭的 Romano H 提出的这个问题开始。你好，Angela 和 Jenna。我在看“献血活动”的超级粉丝版时，Phyllis 说她不让 Bob 在情人节送花到办公室。这太搞笑了。当时有备选台词吗？好的。首先，你不觉得人们像 Jenna 一样，他们就是懂这部剧的语言吗？他们会问，有备选台词吗？是的。他们知道糖果袋，什么都知道。你开始了背景捕捉，我们收到了信件。我喜欢这个。我也喜欢。好吧，Romano，非常感谢你的来信。你知道，我还没看过这一集的超级粉丝版。但在读了你的问题后，我专门去看了这个采访片段。它超级搞笑。我其实……我其实……其实想听听它，然后我们再讨论。好的。我几年前就吸取了教训。情人节不收花。这个地方到处都是嫉妒别人幸福的人。天哪。这太搞笑了，因为，
yes, there's that Valentine's Day episode where flowers just keep coming to Phyllis. Yeah, and everyone gets
really pissed at her. Mm-hmm. Okay. Well, Romano, to answer your question, that talking head that's been
added back into the superfan was actually the one and only candy bag alt that they wrote for
Phyllis and they picked it over the written one. Here's how it was scripted. Philis talking head about
flowers. I learned my lesson years ago. No flowers on Valentine's. Not around here. Too much hate.
It's no wonder they're all alone. Oh. Okay. So they kind of. Different spin.
Same idea, but maybe they went with the less snarky one.
Well, we also got this question from Natasha S in India who said, was there an alternate storyline where Michael unexpectedly meets the girl from the blood drive?
是的，有那一集情人节，花一直送到 Phyllis 那里。是的，每个人都对她很生气。嗯哼。好的。好吧，Romano，回答你的问题，那个被加回超级粉丝版里的采访片段，实际上是他们为 Phyllis 写的唯一一个糖果袋备选台词，他们选择了它而不是写好的那个。剧本里是这样写的。Phyllis 关于花的采访。我几年前就吸取了教训。情人节不收花。在这儿不行。太多的嫉妒。难怪他们都单身。哦。好的。所以他们有点……不同的转折。想法一样，但也许他们选择了那个不那么刻薄的版本。好吧，我们还收到了来自印度 Natasha S 的这个问题，她说，有没有一个替代剧情是 Michael 意外地遇到了那个献血的女孩？
Like, was there going to be a happy ending, basically?
I know. I mean, I was so hopeful for that, but yeah.
Well, Natasha, I went and looked at our table draft from this episode.
You know, I wanted to see, like, was that ever a possibility?
This is the earliest draft we have of this storyline.
And from the very beginning, it just ended with everyone walking out with Michael at the end of the day.
And the girl from the blood drive never does come back.
Here's how it read in the script.
就像，基本上会有个幸福的结局吗？我知道。我是说，我对此充满希望，但确实。好吧，Natasha，我去看了一下我们这一集的剧本草稿。你知道，我想看看，这曾经是一种可能性吗？这是我们关于这个剧情最早的草稿。从一开始，它就以每个人在一天结束时和 Michael 一起走出来而告终。那个献血的女孩再也没有回来。剧本里是这样写的。
Exterior Dunder Mifflin parking lot, end of day.
They all come out of the office together surrounding Michael, who has a little smile.
They say goodbye to each other and head to their cars.
And then Michael has this sort of hopeful talking head as everybody walks out.
And we didn't play it in our original breakdown, but I think we should hear it.
Four months ago, I dated a woman named Holly.
And this is actually the first time that I've even considered getting back into that arena again.
You know what?
外景，Dunder Mifflin 停车场，一天结束。他们一起走出办公室，围着面带微笑的 Michael。他们互相道别，走向各自的车。然后，当每个人走出来时，Michael 有一个充满希望的采访片段。我们最初的拆解中没有播放它，但我认为我们应该听听。四个月前，我和一个叫 Holly 的女人约会。这实际上是我第一次考虑重新回到那个领域。你知道吗？
Sometimes it's not about whether Cinderella gets her slipper back,
but it's about the fact that the prince even picked up the slipper at all.
there's a lot of princesses out there.
You know, they have all different sizes and shapes of feet and hands.
So I think my odds are pretty good.
Oh, my God, that's so sweet.
I know.
Isn't it?
有时候，重要的不是灰姑娘是否找回了她的水晶鞋，而是王子是否捡起了那只鞋。外面有很多公主。你知道，她们有各种不同大小和形状的脚和手。所以我认为我的胜算很大。天哪，太甜了。我知道。不是吗？
And everyone stayed late and all walked out with them.
It's actually really sweet.
Well, people also wrote in because, Jenna, they loved your fast facts.
Oh, about the blood transfusions and stuff? I really loved researching that. Yeah, I think people learned a lot about you too. You'll see.
Nicole M. said, hi, Jenna. I also loved the book, The Immortal Life of Henrietta Lacks. And I saw her portrait while I was in Washington, D.C. So I looked this up online, Jenna, and it's a beautiful portrait. And I guess you can see it. Here's what it said on the website. It said, the Smithsonian.
National Portrait Gallery recognized the life of Henrietta Lacks with the installation of a 2017
portrait by Cadeer Nelson. It was jointly acquired by the National Portrait Gallery and the Smithsonian's
National Museum of African American History and Culture and is shared by the two museums.
每个人都留下来，和他们一起走出来。这其实真的很甜。好吧，人们也写信来，因为 Jenna，他们喜欢你的“快速事实”。哦，关于输血之类的？我真的很喜欢研究那个。是的，我想人们也了解了很多关于你的事。你会看到的。Nicole M 说，你好，Jenna。我也很喜欢《亨丽埃塔·拉克斯的不朽生命》这本书。我在华盛顿特区时看到了她的肖像。所以我上网查了一下，Jenna，那是一幅美丽的肖像。我想你可以看到它。网站上是这样说的。它说，史密森尼国家肖像画廊通过安装 Cadeer Nelson 2017 年的肖像画，认可了亨丽埃塔·拉克斯的一生。它由国家肖像画廊和史密森尼国家非裔美国人历史文化博物馆共同收购，并由两家博物馆共享。
And Nicole goes on to say, I also found a great article about Dr. Charles Drew on the National
Museum of African American History and Culture website. It's titled The Color of Blood. Thank you so
much for sharing about their legacies. Oh my gosh. Well, I love that. And I'm going to have to look up
that portrait. And I can't tell you how many times I think back on that book. It's such a powerful
story. I highly recommend it. Okay. Well, I'm not done with you, lady, because you also got
another book recommendation based off of your fast fact. Mary F. said, I have a book recommendation for
Jenna about the first blood transfusion of the 15-year-old boy. She mentioned.
in this episode. It's titled Blood Work, A Tale of Medicine and Murder in the Scientific
Nicole 继续说，我还在国家非裔美国人历史文化博物馆的网站上找到了一篇关于 Charles Drew 医生的好文章。标题是《血液的颜色》。非常感谢你们分享关于他们遗产的内容。天哪。好吧，我喜欢这个。我得去查查那幅肖像。我无法告诉你我回想起那本书多少次。这是一个如此强大的故事。我强烈推荐它。好的。好吧，我还没说完，女士，因为你还根据你的“快速事实”得到了另一本书的推荐。Mary F 说，我有一个关于 Jenna 提到的 15 岁男孩首次输血的书籍推荐。在这一集中。书名是《血液工作：医学与谋杀的故事》，作者是 Holly Tucker。它真的很好。天哪。好的。好的。最后，Lamia 想让你知道，在沙特阿拉伯，他们的驾照上有血型。是的，我们说过那应该成为一种常态。是的。好吧，还有其他国家已经在做了。好吧，你知道吗？自从这一集第一次播出以来，还没发生过什么？我从来没弄清楚我的血型。哦，Jenna。我知道。
Revolution by Holly Tucker. And it's really good. Oh, my goodness. Okay. Okay. And lastly,
Lamia wants you to know that in Saudi Arabia, they have their blood type on their driver's license.
Yes, we said that that should be a thing. Yeah. Well, there's other countries that are already doing it.
Well, you know what?
Hasn't happened since the first time this episode aired?
I never did figure out my blood type.
Oh, Jenna.
I know.
我说过我会去查，但我没查。这是给我的提醒。好的。好吧，为了结束这一集，我想指出一些关于我所说内容的粉丝邮件。这让我笑坏了。几个人指出了这一点。Ivana 说，哈哈，Angela 说她可能会弄错一两个词和常用短语，然后五分钟后说“过去的闪光”而不是“过去的爆炸”。你说了吗？这让我感到非常有趣。那太搞笑了。我是说，闪光，爆炸。它们都是像光一样的爆裂，不是吗？它们都来自过去。那才是重点。
I said I was gonna and I didn't.
This is my reminder.
Okay.
Well, to wrap up this episode, I did want to point out a little fan mail flurry about something I said.
And this cracked me up.
A few people pointed it out.
Ivana said, L.O.L. Angela saying she might get a word or two wrong.
and common phrases, and then five minutes later says, flash from the past instead of blasts from
但无论如何，我喜欢它。我会继续说错话的，你们。别担心。好了，各位。享受你们的第二杯“献血活动”吧。我是 Jenna Fisher。我是 Angela Kinsey。我们曾一起在《办公室》工作。
the past.
You did?
That amused me greatly.
That's very funny.
I mean, a flash, a blast.
They're both like pops of light, aren't they?
They're from the past.
That's the important part.
我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会拆解一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是“办公室女士”。你好，Angela。你好，Jenna。我觉得我们今天都充满活力。充满活力。
But anyway, I loved it.
And I'll continue saying things wrong, you guys.
Don't you worry.
All right, everyone.
Enjoy your second drink of Blood Drive.
I'm Jenna Fisher.
And I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on the office together.
那是什么意思？充满能量？哦，胀气的豆子。我猜。我是说，我们没有胀气。我没有胀气。好吧。我确实有。
And we're best friends.
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you.
Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
We're the office ladies.
Hello, Angela.
Hi, Jenna.
I feel like we're both full of beans today.
Full of beans.
今天脚很热。我的脚很暖和。我的脚不会发热。我的脚总是冷的。我买了一双新鞋。我喜欢它们。看看它们。看看它们多可爱。哦，它们太可爱了。对吧？但它们里面有像夏尔巴羊毛一样的衬里。为什么，如果你有脚热的倾向，你会买有夏尔巴衬里的鞋子？我没有脚热的倾向。我有脚冷的倾向，但今天是个 90 度的日子。但我还是想穿它们，因为它们太可爱了。还有一件事。它们大半码，因为它们只有整码，所以我必须在 90 度的天气里穿厚袜子配夏尔巴衬里。我的脚很热。一切为了时尚，各位，一切为了时尚。好吧，你了解我。我了解你。听着，当你查找时尚，运动时尚，时尚和运动。
Does that mean?
Full of energy?
Oh, gassy beans.
I guess.
I mean, we're not gassy.
I'm not gassy.
Well.
I do have.
是我。是你。这双鞋是时尚运动鞋。你知道吗？我要拍张照片。这是高级时尚。好了。今天我们讨论的是“献血活动”。第五季第 18 集，由 Brent Forrester 编剧，Randall Einhorn 执导。这是情人节。是的，这是我们的情人节特辑。这也是《办公室》的第 90 集。哇。那甚至不是一个“快速事实”。
have hot feet today, though. My feet are very warm. I don't get hot feet. My feet are always cold.
I bought a new pair of shoes. I love them. Look at them. Look how cute they are. Oh, they're so cute.
Right? But they have like a Sherpa lining in them. Why, if you have a tendency for hot feet,
would you get shoes with Sherpa? I don't have a tendency for hot feet. I have a tendency for cold feet,
but it's a 90-degree day today. But I wanted to wear them because they're so cute. Here's the other thing.
They're a half size too big because they only come in full sizes, so I have to wear a thick sock with a shirp aligning on a 90-degree day. I've got hot feet.
All for fashion, y'all, all for fashion. Well, you know me.
I know you. Listen, when you look up fashion, athletic fashion, fashion and athletic.
我还没到“快速事实”呢。你有很多“快速事实”吗？我觉得这意味着你有很多“快速事实”。我有一个有趣的“快速事实”。是什么？好吧，我们先做一个总结。你知道，我得按顺序来，女士们。哦，好的。
It's me. It's you. And this shoe is a fashion athletic shoe. You know what? I'm going to take a picture of it. It's high fashion.
All right. Today we're talking about Blood Drive.
Season 5, episode 18, written by Brent Forrester and directed by Randall Einhorn.
It's Valentine's Day.
Yeah, this was our Valentine's Day episode.
It was also the 90th episode of The Office.
Wow.
That's not even a fast fact.
好的。今天是情人节。嗯哼。斯克兰顿商业园的停车场正在举行献血活动。Michael 在献血时遇到了一位年轻女子，但在他能得到她的名字和电话号码之前就晕倒了。所以他决定为办公室举办一个“孤独之心”派对。好吧，他很暴躁，因为他是单身，而且，你知道，他不想庆祝情人节。他不想。
I haven't even gotten to fast facts yet.
Do you have a lot of fast facts?
I feel like this means you have a lot of fast facts.
I have a fun fast fact.
What is it?
Well, let's do a summary first.
You know, I have to go in order ladies.
Oh, okay.
他当然不需要 Jim、Pam、Phyllis 和 Bob 在他面前炫耀他们的情侣午餐。他们的情侣爱在他面前。我今天不需要爱在我面前。这就是 Michael 说的。不是我。我想要爱在我面前。什么？我不知道。
Okay.
It is Valentine's Day.
Mm-hmm.
And there's a blood drive taking place in the parking lot of the Scranton Business Park.
Michael meets a young woman while giving blood, but he passes out before he can get her name and phone number.
So he decides to throw a lonely hearts party for the office.
Well, he's grumpy because he's single and, you know, he doesn't want to celebrate Valentine's Day.
He doesn't.
好的。“快速事实”第一条。什么？你看上去很兴奋。你还在笑“爱在我面前”吗？是的。好的。“快速事实”第一条是什么？
and he certainly doesn't need Jim and Pam and Phyllis and Bob rubbing their couples' lunch in his face.
Their couples love in his face.
I don't need love in my face today.
That's what Michael was saying.
Not me.
I want love in my face.
What?
I don't know.
“快速事实”第一条是关于我们停车场里那辆献血车的一些事实。它让我想起了一点像工作巴士。是的。他们是不是只有一辆巴士，然后把它改装成任何东西？不，女士。哦。Randy Cordray 告诉我，我们用的是伯班克普罗维登斯圣约瑟夫医院的一辆真正的献血车。我们用了三天。
Okay.
Fast fact number one.
What?
You look so excited.
Are you still laughing about love in my face?
I am.
Okay.
What's fast fact number one?
所以周一，布景师进去，把它变成了我们目的所需的一种看起来更通用的献血车。周二，我们在献血车里拍摄了所有的场景。周三，它配备了真正的护士，演员和工作人员中的任何人都可以真正献血。我记得那个，因为每个人都走来走去，贴着一张写着“我献了血”的小贴纸，而我没有。我感到有点羞愧。那天我在外景地。那是我们拍摄餐厅场景的那天，所以我那天也没能献血。好吧，我去献血，他们把我拒之门外。因为你的娇小，所以你……
Fast fact number one are some facts about our Bloodmobile that was in our parking lot.
It reminded me a little bit of like the work bus bus.
Yeah.
Do they have one bus they just trick out for everything?
No, ma'am.
Oh.
Randy Cordray told me we used a real Bloodmobile from the Providence St. Joseph's Hospital in Burbank.
We had it for three days.
因为你必须至少 110 磅才能献血。这是真的。所以他们把我拒之门外。什么？这是一个事实。我知道。好的。这是真的。
So on Monday, the set dressers went in and they turned it into kind of a more generic
looking blood mobile for our purposes. On Tuesday, we did all of our scenes inside the blood mobile.
And on Wednesday, it was staffed with actual nurses and anyone in the cast and crew could actually
donate blood. I remember that because everyone was walking around with a little sticker that said,
I gave blood, and I didn't have one. I felt a little shame. I was on location that day. That's the day
we shot the restaurant stuff, so I didn't get to give blood that day either.
Well, I went to give blood and they turned me away.
Because of your tininess, then you're...
不，那是真的。这是真的。我从来没有因为献血而被拒之门外。好吧，我还是不能……我是个健壮的女士。你不健壮。是的，我是。你是孩子们所说的“厚实”。
Because you have to weigh at least 110 pounds to give blood.
It's true.
So they turned me away.
What?
That's a fact.
I know.
Okay.
It's true.
T-H-I-C-C-C。顺便说一句，我只是这么说，因为我只是这么说。有人在我的 Instagram 评论里写了。哦，Angela 很厚实，我不得不去谷歌搜索。我想这是件好事，女士。我想这意味着我们的后备箱里有点货，但在所有正确的地方。好的，那我就把它当作一种赞美。好吧，根据城市词典，这是件好事。
No, that is true.
It is true.
I've never been turned away from giving blood.
Well, I still can't...
I'm a hearty lady.
You're not hearty.
Yes, I am.
You're what the kids call thick.
继续。是的。好了，现在是“快速事实”第二条，我太兴奋了，女士。好的。因为我查了献血活动和献血车的历史。你们，我想让你们知道几天前，Jenna 发短信给我说，我对我的“快速事实”第二条感到非常兴奋。
T-H-I-C-C-C.
By the way, I'm only saying that, because I'm only saying that.
Someone wrote in one of my comments on Instagram.
Oh, Angela is thick, and I had to Google it.
I think it's a good thing, lady.
I think it means we got a little junk in her trunk, but in all the right places.
Okay, well, then I'll take it as a compliment.
Well, according to Urban Dictionary, it's a good thing.
我当时说，好的。事情是这样的。我有点像个科学书呆子。你是。就像，我在过去两年里读过的我最喜欢的书是这本叫《亨丽埃塔·拉克斯的不朽生命》的书。你知道它是关于什么的吗？我不知道。
Go ahead.
Yeah.
All right.
Now it's fast fact number two, and I'm just so excited, lady.
Okay.
Because I looked up the history of blood drives and blood mobiles.
You guys, I want you to know a few days ago, Jenna texted me and was like, I'm really excited
about my fast fact number two.
好的。这个女人在 1951 年做了一次癌症手术。他们取了她的一些细胞。这就像是一件事，比如，你捐赠，我加上引号，你的细胞用于医学研究，但这是在没有你同意的情况下。好吧，无论如何，这个女人的细胞非常健壮。它们就像是至今所有最重要的医学研究的基础。比如，她的细胞是我们有脊髓灰质炎疫苗的原因。
And I was like, okay.
Here's the thing.
I'm a little bit of kind of a science nerd.
You are.
Like, my favorite book that I read in the last two years is this book called The Immortal
Life of Henrietta Lax.
Do you know what it's about?
I have no idea.
太神奇了。她就像是超人。她对科学的贡献是……而且她的后代和家人从未得到过补偿。哦。所以这本书很迷人。我对献血活动和献血车的研究，触及了我身上同样迷恋医学发现的那一部分。所以你准备好了吗？
Okay.
This woman in 1951, she had a cancer surgery.
and they took some of her cells.
This was like a thing where, like, you donate.
I'm putting that in quotes, your cells for medical research, but it's without your consent.
Well, anyway, this woman's cells were so hearty.
They are, like, the basis of all of the most important medical research to this day.
Like, her cells are why we have a polio vaccine.
我希望你能看到，Jenna，现在，你们。她太生动了。她的手在动，就像她在弯曲手指，然后她在指点，然后她在向天空伸展。开始吧。所以要谈论血库和献血车，我们必须从人们对血液携带疾病这一想法的迷恋开始。好的。现在，这可以追溯到埃及人。他们会做那种事，就是割伤自己，让你流血排出疾病。好的。所以就像他们走在正确的轨道上。就像是的，你的血液里可能有让你生病的东西，但这并不是解决方案，对吧？对，对。所以正确的
It's amazing.
She's, like, superhuman.
It's just like her contribution to science is overwerews.
And yet her descendants and her family have never been compensated.
Oh.
And so the book is fascinating.
And my research into blood drives and blood mobiles, it touches on that same part of me that is just fascinated by, like, medical discoveries.
So are you ready?
想法，错误的解决方案。我觉得《草原小屋》里有一集，他们放了一堆，沼泽里那些东西是什么？水蛭。水蛭在某人身上放血。同样的想法。好的。好的。所以有人想到，你需要的是给生病的人输健康的血，输血。是的。好的。我能找到的第一次尝试输血可以追溯到 1492 年。警告，有点病态。好的。教皇英诺森八世当时陷入了昏迷。
I wish you could see, Jenna, right now, you guys.
She is so animated.
Her hands are moving, like she's bending her fingers and then she's pointing and then she's reaching to the sky.
go. So in order to talk about blood banking and blood mobiles, we kind of have to start with
people's fascination with the idea that blood carries disease. Okay. Now, this goes back to
the Egyptians. They would do that thing where you would cut yourself and let yourself bleed out
your sickness. Okay. So it's like they're on the right track. Like yes, your blood can have
things in it that are making you sick, but this is not the solution, right? Right, right. So right
所以他们取了三个 10 岁男孩的血，作为输血放进教皇的嘴里，但他们都死了。教皇和男孩们。是的。是的。哦，天哪。好吧，那很恐怖？
idea, wrong solution. I feel like there was like a little house on the prairie where they put a
bunch of, what are those things in the swamp? Leeches. Leaches all over someone to bleed them out.
Same idea. Okay. Okay. So then someone got the idea that what you need is you need like to give
the person with the sick blood healthy blood, a blood transfusion. Yeah. Okay. The first attempted blood transfusion
that I could find dates back to 1492.
Warning, it's a bit morbid.
Okay.
Pope Innocent the 8th was going into a coma.
非常恐怖。野蛮。是的。有点吓人。可能会困扰我。继续。我很抱歉。好的。
So they took the blood of three 10-year-old boys,
and they put it in the Pope's mouth as a transfusion,
but all of them died.
The Pope and the boys.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
Well, that is gruesome?
第一次某种意义上成功的输血是在 1667 年的法国。路易十四的医生从一只羊身上取血。他把它输进了一个 15 岁男孩的体内，那个男孩活了下来。现在，为什么？那个男孩生病了吗，还是这只是一个实验？我想他需要它。好的。我想这是一次医疗紧急情况，他们当时想，让我们试试这个。
Very gruesome.
Barbaric.
Yes.
Slightly scary.
Might haunt me.
Continue.
I'm very sorry.
Okay.
好的。我不是 100% 确定。我可能应该给出免责声明，这是“谷歌女士”的另一个片段。好的。好的。四到五篇文章。所以后来我们在 20 世纪初有了很多一般的血液科学发现。比如，我们发现有四种主要的血型，对吧？
The first sort of successful blood transfusion was in France in 1667.
King Louis the 14th doctor took the blood out of a sheep.
And he put it into a 15-year-old boy who survived.
Now, why?
Was the boy sick or was this just an experiment?
I think he needed it.
Okay.
I think it was a medical emergency and they were like, let's try this.
他们弄清楚了如何匹配人，血液的捐赠者和接受者。你知道你的血型吗？我不知道。我应该知道，因为我生孩子时他们告诉过我。所以当我生 Isabel 时，我发现我是 A 型阳性，她也是，我妈妈也是。嘿。我们都是 A 型阳性。我总是对自己说，哦，记得去查一下，这样你就知道你的血型了。
Okay.
I'm not 100% sure.
I probably should have given the disclaimer that this is another segment of a lady who Googles.
Okay.
Four to five articles.
So then we had a lot of general blood science discovery that happened in the early 1900s.
Like, we discovered that there are four main blood types, right?
哦，是的，太迷人了。好的，继续。我想我们应该把它写在驾照上。我们的血型。是的，我想那会很聪明。我想这是个好主意。所以无论如何，我很抱歉。我希望你对这段历史感兴趣。
They figured out how to match people together, a donor and a recipient of blood.
Do you know your blood type?
I don't.
I should know because they told me when I had my kids.
So when I had Isabel, I found out I was A positive, and so is she, and so is my mom.
Hey.
We're all A positive.
I always think to myself, oh, remember to look that up so you know your blood type.
我觉得它很迷人。跟我在一起。所以现在我们要去俄罗斯，好的？好的。这位俄罗斯医生意识到我需要做的是把血从一个人输给另一个人。所以他们会做这种人对人的输血。好的。问题是它真的。
Oh, yeah, it's so fascinating.
Okay, go.
I think we should put that on our driver's licenses.
Our blood type.
Yeah, I think that would be smart.
I think that's a good idea.
So anyway, I'm so sorry.
I hope you're interested in this history.
真的很难及时让捐赠者找到接受者，比如便利性，对吧？对，对。所以那行得通。人对人的输血是有效的。这很好，但有一个时间因素，还有一个便利因素。那时，芝加哥的一位名叫 Bernard Fantas 的医生有了让捐赠者捐血并储存血液的想法。这是可能的，因为他们了解到你可以往血液里加点东西来防止它凝固。好的。所以现在血液储存成为可能。他们认为 Bernard Fantas 因创建了第一个血库而受到赞誉。
I find it fascinating.
Stay with me.
So now we're going to go to Russia, okay?
Okay.
And this doctor in Russia realizes what I need to do is take blood from one person to another person.
And so they would do these person-to-person transfusions.
Okay.
The problem is that it was really.
好的。Bernard 加油。但也许对活体捐赠献血活动最重要的贡献者是 Charles Drew 医生。记住这个名字。好的。Charles Drew 医生。他是一位了不起的。美国外科医生和医学研究员。他毕生致力于研究和改进。
really hard to get a giver to a recipient in time, like the convenience, right? Right, right. So that was
working. Person-to-person blood transfusions were working. It was great, but there was a time factor,
and there was like a convenience factor. That is when a doctor in Chicago named Bernard
Fantas had the idea of getting donors and storing their blood. And this was possible because
they learned there was something you could add to blood to keep it from clotting.
Okay.
So now blood storage was possible.
And they believe that Bernard Fantas is credited with creating the first blood bank.
血液储存和输血的技术。他的研究促成了大规模血库的建立。他们是美国红十字会在二战期间能够收集超过 1300 万品脱血液的原因。而且看起来献血车也是 Charles Drew 医生的创意。Charles Drew 医生。是的。是的。因为现在，你知道，东西可以来到你身边并获取你的血液。
Okay.
Go Bernard.
But perhaps the most important contributor to live donor blood drives was Dr. Charles Drew.
Remember this name.
Okay.
Dr. Charles Drew.
He was an amazing.
American surgeon and medical researcher. He dedicated his life to researching and improving the
顺便说一句，一月是全国献血者月。这总是一个好的新年决心，你可以在红十字会网站上找到献血的方法。就是这样。我喜欢所有的内容，除了开头的部分。我知道。我很抱歉开头的部分，但那是记录在案的第一次输血，
techniques for blood storage and blood transfusions. His research is what has contributed to the
creation of large-scale blood banks. They are the reason why the American Red Cross was able to
collect more than 13 million pints of blood during World War II. And it also appears that
the bloodmobile was the brainchild of Dr. Charles Drew.
Dr. Charles Drew.
Yes.
Because now, you know, the thing could come to you and get your blood.
根据我读过的四到五家网站。无论如何，读读《亨丽埃塔·拉克斯的不朽生命》这本书。它真的很好。好的。还有，Charles Drew 医生。Charles Drew 医生。我们正在做一集献血活动，因为你创造了献血车。没有他，我们不可能在停车场里有一辆。
By the way, January is National Blood Donor Month.
It's always a good New Year's resolution,
and you can find ways to give blood at the Red Cross website.
There you go.
I loved all of it except for the beginning part.
I know.
I'm sorry for the beginning part,
but that is the first blood transfusion on record,
好了，“快速事实”第三条，我们收到了很多邮件。人们想知道是谁扮演了在车里和 Michael 一起献血的那个女人。Chelsea D 说，我觉得 Michael 在献血活动中遇到那个女人的方式是我在电视节目中见过的最好的“邂逅”之一。好吧，各位，她是由 Katie Asselton 扮演的。她是一个快乐。
according to the four to five websites that I read.
Anyway, read the book The Immortal Life of Henrietta Lacks.
It's really good.
Okay.
Also, Dr. Charles Drew.
Dr. Charles Drew.
We're having a blood drive episode because you created the Bloodmobile.
We couldn't have had one in our parking lot without him.
我崇拜她。她太甜了。我们认识她。是的。我们是她的朋友。你们，你们可能从《联盟》或《聚在一起》或《大群》中认出她。她在《大群》里演得太好了。太好了。
All right.
Fast fact number three, we got a lot of mail.
People want to know who played the woman giving blood in the truck with Michael.
Chelsea D. said,
I thought the way Michael met that woman at the Blood Drive
is one of the best meet-cutes I've ever seen on a TV show.
Well, everyone, she was played by Katie Asselton.
She is a delight.
哦，天哪。好吧，我们联系了她。我们联系了。她告诉我们她是如何在《办公室》中获得角色的。嘿，伙计们。希望你们都很好。我想念看到你们的脸。但我很高兴你们联系了我。
I adore her.
She's so sweet.
We know her.
Yes.
We're friends with her.
You guys, you probably recognize her from the league or togetherness or Legion.
She's so good in Legion.
So good.
能在《办公室》工作，过去是，将来也永远是我职业生涯的一个真正亮点。多么激动人心。这是我的第一份大工作。所以，是的，这是一个很好的开始，对吧？所以让我直接回答。Alison Jones，她是很多人的拥护者，也是我的拥护者。她来自缅因州，我也来自缅因州，我们一直有那种非常美好的联系，但她叫我来参加这个。而且，你知道，当试镜一拍即合时，这一次感觉就是那样，就像其中一个
Oh, man.
Well, we reached out to her.
We did.
And she told us how she got her role in the office.
Hi, guys.
I hope you guys are great.
I miss seeing your faces.
But I'm thrilled that you reached out.
事情，我当时想，哦，天哪，这可能真的会发生。它确实发生了。他们买了它。而且它真的像为我开启了一切。能成为那个节目的一部分，我立刻获得了信誉。我只是觉得，这是一个多么有趣、有趣的第一角色。太酷了。你知道，我很久没看这一集了。当它演到那个场景时，我当时想，哦，天哪，那是 Katie。她太迷人了。
Getting to work on the office has and will ever be just a real career highlight for me.
What a thrill.
It was my first big job.
So, yeah, what a way to start, right?
So let me just jump right in to answer.
Alison Jones, who is a champion of so many of us, was a champion of mine. She is from Maine, and I am from
Maine, and we just have always had that really beautiful connection, but she called me in for this.
And, you know, when an audition just clicks, and this one felt that way, and it was like one of
就像，我希望她和 Michael 约会，你知道吗？我知道。他们太可爱了。我也是，Angela。当我看到它时，我当时想，哦，天哪，是 Katie。她是一位了不起的女演员。她也是一位导演。她导演了三部电影。
those things where I was like, oh, man, this might actually happen. And it did. They bought it.
and that it really like started everything for me.
I got just instant cred getting to be a part of that show.
And I'm just like, what a fun, fun first role it was.
So cool.
You know, I hadn't watched this episode in a long time.
And when it got to that scene, I was like, oh my God, there's Katie.
And she is so incredibly charming.
她最新的电影由 Diane Keaton、Elizabeth Lale 和 Nicole Byer 主演。它叫《麦克和丽塔》。她现在正在进行后期制作。我告诉她，当它上映时，我们会在播客里大声疾呼，这样人们就能找到它。是的，那是一个很棒的演员阵容。好吧，女士，这就是全部。我的“快速事实”。好吧，我想我们应该休息一下，因为当我们回来时，我可能需要给 Jim 一点
Like, I want her and Michael to date, you know?
I know.
They're so cute.
Same, Angela.
When I saw it, I was like, oh, my gosh, it's Katie.
And she's an amazing actress.
She's also a director.
She's directed three films.
阴影。真的吗？是的。我迫不及待想知道为什么。我可能有一些俗气的话要说。哦。哦，那些总是我最喜欢的消息。你是什么意思？
Her latest film is starring Diane Keaton, Elizabeth Lale, and Nicole Byer.
It's called Mack and Rita.
She's in post-production on it now.
And I told her that when it comes out, we'll put a shout out in the pod so that people can find it.
Yeah, that's a great cast.
Well, lady, that is all.
of my fast facts.
Well, I think we should go to break, because when we come back, I might need to throw Jim a little
你会发短信给我说，嘿，你能给我打电话吗？我有件俗气的事要说。我当时想，哦，我等不及了。我当时想，放下一切。我必须给 Angela 打电话。好了。我们会回来的。嘿，我是 Jen Hatmaker。
shade.
Really?
Yeah.
I can't wait to find out why.
I might have something tacky to say.
Oh.
Oh, those are always my favorite messages.
What do you mean?
这就是我在中年学到的。快乐不是你在所有工作完成后赚取的奖励。快乐就是工作。这就是“为了爱”这个新系列的主题。神圣的“是”。这是有目的地选择快乐、休息和愉悦。因为对自己说“是”，那是最终让你能用其他人填满你的桌子的事情。来和我一起找到你神圣的“是”吧。
You'll, like, text me and be like, hey, can you call me?
I have something tacky to say.
And I'm like, oh, I can't wait.
I'm like, drop everything.
I have to call Angela.
All right.
We'll be back.
Hey, it's Jen Hatmaker.
关注并收听“为了爱”，无论你在哪里获取播客。Angela，当你在休息时去喝茶时，Sam 告诉我一些我不知道的、超越迷人的事情。这是关于血液的更多新闻。什么？Sam，你能分享一下吗？是的，他们有献血者和血库，就像人类一样，但那是给狗的。
Here's what I've learned in midlife.
Joy isn't the reward you earn after all the work is done.
Joy is the work.
That's what this new series on For the Love is all about.
The sacred yes.
It's choosing delight, rest, and pleasure on purpose.
Because saying yes to yourself, that's the thing that finally lets you fill your table with everybody else.
Come find your sacred yes with me.
噢。而且它们，同样的事情，它们捐赠小袋血液。Sam 见到了一只狗，它每个月在你的兽医那里捐一次血。它的名字叫 Ben，它是一只金毛猎犬，它有一件带心形图案的小背心。它是一个非常好的男孩。哦，那太甜了。非常好的男孩。那是我甚至不会想到的事情。我知道。
Follow and listen to For the Love.
wherever you get your podcasts.
Angela, while you were getting tea during your break,
Sam told me something beyond fascinating that I didn't know.
It's more news about blood.
What?
Sam, will you please share?
Yeah, they have blood donors and banks just like for humans, but for dogs.
但当然。当然。好了。我们开始吧？让我们开始吧。你猜怎么着？什么？Techstar 有一位代表说，手机有一个全新的操作系统。
Aw.
And they, same thing, they donate little pouches of blood.
And Sam got to meet a dog that donates his blood once a month at your vet.
His name is Ben and he's a golden retriever and he has a little vest with a heart on it.
And he's a very good boy.
Oh, that is so sweet.
Very good boy. That is like stuff I don't even think about.
I know.
他可以和 Michael Scott 会面，但 Michael Scott 从来不在。我不知道为什么。好吧，Pam 说如果他们安装了这个允许的新电话系统。
But of course.
Of course.
All right.
Should we get started?
Let's get started.
Guess what?
What?
There is a rep from Techstar who says there's a whole new operating system for the phones.
呼叫者直接联系销售人员，那基本上是她工作的 95%。所以她显然永远不会让这个人见到 Michael，因为她不想失去工作。我不认为 Michael 会让她走。我只想说，Pam，你不必担心，因为 Michael 认为你是他的私人秘书。是的。所以即使你安装了那个电话系统，你知道这意味着什么吗？她可能不得不花更多时间陪 Michael。你不会那么忙。所以他会说，
And he could like meet with Michael Scott, but Michael Scott's never around.
I wonder why.
Well, Pam says if they get this new phone system that allows.
the caller to contact the salespeople directly, that's basically 95% of her job. So she is clearly
never letting this guy meet Michael because she doesn't want to lose her job. I don't think Michael
would ever let her go. I just want to say, Pam, you don't have to worry because Michael thinks
you're his personal secretary. Yes. So even if you got that phone system, you know what it would
mean? She'd probably have to spend more time with Michael. You wouldn't be as busy. So he'd be like,
Pam，进我的办公室。这是真的。我必须说，我很欣赏当一个人接听时。我打电话给企业时的电话。我也是。我不喜欢那个新电话系统。我喜欢找真人。我也喜欢。我很健谈。好吧，我想让你知道在 49 秒时，Pam 的桌子上贴了几条消息。我看到了同样的事情。你看到了？好的。我想知道 Nick 是谁。哦，是的。有一条消息。在 PINStar 的便利贴上，顺便说一句，PINStar 是宾夕法尼亚州的一家银行分行。喜欢这些细节。Nick 在办公室待了一整天。是的。纸条上是这么写的。我是说，Nick 是谁？好吧，我知道 Nick 会是谁。Nick 会是我们的 IT 人员。Nick 会是？不，Nick 会是我们的 IT 人员。
Pam, come in my office. It's true. I have to say, I appreciate when a person answers.
the phone when I call a business. Me too. I wouldn't like that new phone system. I like to get a
human. I do too. I'm chatty. Well, I want you to know at 49 seconds, there were a few messages taped
to Pam's desk. I saw the same thing. You did? Okay. I want to know who Nick is. Oh yeah. There's like a
message. On a PINStar post-it note, which by the way, PINStar was a bank branch in Pennsylvania.
Love those details. Nick in office all day.
Yeah. That's what the note said. I mean, who is Nick? Well, I know who Nick will be. Nick will be our IT guy.
Nick will be? No, Nick will be our IT guy.
不，我很抱歉。那只是让我笑了。好的，所以我们不知道 Nick 是谁，但未来有一天，我们将有一个叫 Nick 的 IT 人员。是的。还有，Jenna，那是你的购物清单吗？那是我的购物清单。我知道你在买绿茶。还有石榴籽和石榴籽和松子。你在干什么？发生了什么？好的，当时我真的很喜欢那个沙拉，里面有石榴籽和松子。当我看到那张便利贴时，我当时想，哦，天哪，我应该再做一次那个沙拉。我喜欢它。我想我认出了你的笔迹。我当时想，那是 Jenna 的购物清单。确实是。你还注意到我的桌子上有一张我和 John 的照片吗？我们站着。这是我们的订婚照。是的。我们拍了。
No, I'm sorry. That just made me laugh. Okay, so we don't know who Nick is, but someday in the future, we're going to have an IT guy named Nick.
Yes. Also, Jenna, was that your grocery list?
It was my grocery list. I know you're getting green tea. And pomegranate seeds and pomegranate seeds and
pine nuts. What were you? What's happening? Okay, there was the salad I really liked at the time and it had
pomegranate seeds and pine nuts in it. When I saw that sticky note, I was like, oh my gosh, I should make
that salad again. I loved it. I thought I recognized your handwriting. I was like, that's Jenna's grocery
list. It was. Did you also notice there is a photo of me and John on my desk. We're standing up.
This was our engagement photo. Yeah. We did.
这张特别的照片。那是我们在 Jim 父母家拍摄的那天，他带我参观。我们带了这套额外的衣服，我们在后院摆了姿势。Jim 的桌子上也有一张。他有，但在他的桌子上，我坐在他的腿上。对。而在你的桌子上，你站着。是的。所以我想这是他们为这一集情人节拍摄的，我们的订婚照。Jim 要去救 Pam 了。他说，Michael Scott 在这儿。然后接下来的这一段太搞笑了。Jenna，你很兴奋能参与其中。我记得你当时说你很兴奋。因为，你知道，Michael 走出来，就像，嘿，Jim 就像，Jimbo。而不是 Michael 像，什么，你在说什么？他立刻就像，噢，我们在做什么？
this special photo shoot. It was the day that we shot at Jim's parents' house when he's showing me
around. We brought this extra set of clothes and we posed in the backyard. Jim has one on his desk,
too. He does, but on his desk, I'm sitting on his lap. Right. And on yours, you're standing.
Yes. So this was, I think they went out for this Valentine's Day episode, our engagement photos.
Jim's going to come to Pam's rescue. He's like, Michael Scott here. And then this next bit was
so funny. And Jenna, you were so excited to be part of it. I remember you were like so excited.
Because, you know, Michael walks out and it's like, hey, and Jim is like, Jimbo. And instead of Michael
being like, what, what are you talking about? He's instantly like, ooh, what are we doing?
我们在演戏。我们在演戏。我太兴奋了。然后突然之间，每个人都是 Fonzie。我知道。这真的很有趣。我们拍摄那天在笑。做这些真的很有趣。我觉得我应该让你知道，电话技术代表是由 Rob Brownstein 扮演的。他对我来说很眼熟。好吧，他上过《神探阿蒙》。嗯哼。他还出演了短命的《法律与秩序：洛杉矶》。哦。
We're doing a bit. We're doing a bit. I'm so excited. And then all of a sudden, everyone's Fonzie.
I know. It was really fun. We were laughing on the day when we shot that. It was so fun to do those.
I feel like I should let you know that the phone tech rep was played by Rob Brownstein.
He looked familiar to me.
Well, he's been on Monk.
Mm-hmm.
He was also on the short-lived Law & Order Los Angeles.
Oh.
他出演过《绝命毒师》和《广告狂人》。但女士？什么？他最新的电影。是的。还没上映。哦，不。不，等等，等等。
He's been on Breaking Bad and on Mad Men.
But lady?
What?
His latest movie.
Yeah.
Which has not come out yet.
Oh, no.
No, wait, wait, wait.
是《疾速追杀》吗？不。哦。它叫《蜂鸟》。哦，我会去看的。这是一部科幻电影。听听标语。我加入了。
Is it John Wick?
No.
Oh.
It's called Hummingbird.
Oh, I'll go see it.
It's a sci-fi movie.
Listen to the tagline.
I'm in.
当深受爱戴的心灵感应超级英雄“蜂鸟”，也被称为 Lola Laxman，在一次大战后被遗弃等死时，她与魔鬼达成协议以挽救生命。算我一个。算我们两个。是的。我们要去看《蜂鸟》。我要和你一起演科幻片。听着，你知道吗？你可以成为那个进来提供科学依据的科学实验室技术员女士。
When beloved telepathic superhero Hummingbird, also known as Lola Laxman, is left for dead after a major battle, she makes a deal with the devil to save her life.
Sign me up.
Sign us both up.
Yeah.
We're going to go see Hummingbird.
I'm going to be in a sci-fi with you.
Listen, you know what?
you can be the science lab tech lady that comes in and gives the science behind the thing.
好的。你知道我喜欢演什么样的电影吗，叫什么来着？《极度恐慌》。不。不。不是那部电影。和 Kurt Russell 一起，那部《怪形》。呃。
Okay.
You know what I would love to be in is a movie like, what's it called?
Outbreak.
No.
Not that movie.
With Kurt Russell, the thing.
Ew.
《怪形》。呃。是的。恶心。你看过吗？我觉得我看了部分，我不得不放弃。它太好了。那部电影里的实用特效非常出色。
The thing.
Ew.
Yeah.
Gross.
Have you seen it?
I feel like I saw part of it and I had to bail.
It's so good.
The practical effects in that movie are outstanding.
好了。我们应该进入这一集吗？我们应该。正如你们所知，正在举行情人节献血活动。我想指出，斯克兰顿商业园在装饰上全力以赴。他们确实做到了。我是说，有一个“情人节快乐”的横幅。有三个红色的丘比特在射心形箭，墙上贴满了带有爱的信息的大心。柜台上有一个花瓶，里面有像塑料心形的东西。电梯门上有一个巨大的心，当他们进去时会打开。是谁在装饰斯克兰顿商业园？我有一个理论。你的理论是什么？我认为是 Phyllis。她嫁给了 Bob Vance。他是五大家族之一。你可能是对的，因为她不能再做 Dunder Mifflin 的派对策划人了。是的，她就像，Bob，我有一箱心和丘比特。我可以把它们放在大厅里。我喜欢 Phyllis 和 Bob 说话时的声音。好吧，我们还发现这是 Jim 和 Pam 作为未婚夫妻的第一个也是唯一一个情人节。嗯哼。
All right. Should we get into this episode? We should. There is a Valentine's Day blood drive happening, as you guys know. And I want to point out that the Scranton Business Park went all out with decorations. They really did. I mean, there's a Happy Valentine's Day banner. There's three Red Cupid shooting heart arrows, big hearts with love messages all on the walls. There's like a vase with like little plastic hearty things on the counter. There's a
giant heart on the elevator doors that opens when they get in. Who is decorating the Scranton
business park? I have a theory. What's your theory? I think it's Phyllis. She's married to Bob Vance. He's
one of the five families. You might be right, since she can't be the Dundermifflin party planner
anymore. Yeah, she's like, Bob, I've got a bin of hearts and cupids. I can put him around the lobby.
I love Phyllis's voice when she's talking to Bob. Well, we also find out that it is Jim and
Pam's first and only Valentine's Day as fiancée's.
Mm-hmm.
你在两分 41 秒看到 Pam 戴着一些真正可爱的粉红色吊坠耳环，扎着俏皮的马尾辫吗？我喜欢那个俏皮的马尾辫。我也是。我确实喜欢俏皮的马尾辫。Kelly 收到了一张来自秘密崇拜者的情人节贺卡。嗯哼。她打开它。上面写着玫瑰是红的，紫罗兰是蓝的。
Did you see it two minutes, 41 seconds that Pam's got some real cute dangle pink earrings on a sassy ponytail?
I love the sassy ponytail.
Me too.
I do love a sassy ponytail.
Kelly has received a Valentine from a secret admirer.
Mm-hmm.
She opens it up.
It says roses are red, violets are blue.
是时候进行牙齿清洁了，也许还要检查一下。我想说这引起了我的共鸣。我曾经是 Kelly，我收到过看起来像个人节日贺卡的东西，然后它是来自比如我的干洗店。是的。你知道我的意思吗？或者情人节贺卡，我以为，哦，哦，或者生日。你有没有收到过生日问候？是的。
It's time for your dental cleaning and maybe a checkup too.
I want to say that this resonated with me.
I have been Kelly where I've gotten what looks like a personal holiday card and then it's from like my dry cleaner.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Or a Valentine's Day card that I think, oh, oh, or birthday.
Do you ever get the birthday greetings?
Yes.
来自比如你从妇科医生那里收到生日问候。对。正是。在圣诞节，你知道，很多企业会寄出像公司圣诞贺卡。是的。我把它们和所有家人朋友的圣诞贺卡贴在一起。这让我觉得很有趣，比如，哦，那是朋友的家人。他们太可爱了。
From like you get a birthday greeting from your gynecologist.
Right.
Exactly.
At Christmas, you know, a lot of businesses will send out like a company Christmas card.
Yeah.
I tape them right up with all my family and friends' Christmas cards.
It just tickles me to be like, oh, there's like my friend's family.
They're so cute.
那是我的阿姨和叔叔。那是我的空调公司。是的。就在那里，巨大的空调机上挂着一个小花环。嗯哼。如果你寄给我，它就会挂在墙上，各位。这是关于你的事实。我们应该谈谈 Pam 美丽的情人节花艺布置吗？
And there's my aunt and uncle.
And there's my air conditioning company.
Yep.
Right there with a little wreath over a giant air conditioning unit.
Mm-hmm.
It goes up on the wall, guys, if you send it to me.
This is true about you.
Should we talk about Pam's beautiful Valentine's Day floral arrangement?
哦，我们应该谈谈，我正在为这次谈话戴上眼镜。哇。嗯哼。在三分三秒，我们得到了 Jim 给 Pam 的花艺布置的一个很好的镜头。现在我要变得俗气了。哦，好的。就是这样。我小时候有个朋友在当地的花店工作。
Oh, we shall, and I'm putting on my glasses for this conversation.
Wow.
Mm-hmm.
At three minutes and three seconds, we get a real nice shot of this flower arrangement that Jim gave Pam.
And now I'm about to be tacky.
Oh, okay.
Here it is.
I had a friend growing up who worked at our local flower shop.
哦，我们会的，为了这次谈话我特意戴上了眼镜。哇。嗯哼。在三分零三秒的时候，我们看到了吉姆送给帕姆的那束花的一个非常好的镜头。现在我要说点俗气的了。哦，好吧。就是这个。我小时候有个朋友在当地的花店工作。
She told me that carnations are the cheapest flower.
and they use them to fill out arrangements.
And another cheap flower they use are daisies.
So if you want to go cheap, you get carnations and daisies.
Jim's Valentine flowers are all carnations and daisies, I'm just saying.
I noticed it as well.
So I looked in the script.
I wanted to see if there was a script note about Jim's flower arrangement to Pam.
她告诉我康乃馨是最便宜的花，他们用它来填充花束。他们用的另一种便宜的花是雏菊。所以如果你想省钱，就买康乃馨和雏菊。吉姆的情人节花束全是康乃馨和雏菊，我只是随口一提。我也注意到了。所以我查了剧本。我想看看剧本里有没有关于吉姆送给帕姆的花束的备注。
I want to hear it because I have a theory that I will prove.
I think I can prove it.
Okay.
Here is what the script said.
There was a note.
There is a small bouquet of non-rose flowers on Pam's desk.
Okay.
Well, I think Phil Schae from Props ran with this because later in the episode,
我想听听，因为我有一个理论，我要证明它。我想我能证明。好的。剧本上是这么写的。有一个备注。帕姆的桌上有一小束非玫瑰花。好吧。嗯，我想道具组的菲尔·谢（Phil Schae）执行了这个想法，因为在这一集的后面，
when they go to the fancy restaurant with Bob and Phyllis,
the same arrangement is on all the tables.
Really?
Yes.
And if you look up cheap flowers for big events,
Carnations and Daisies, if you have an event, like a wedding or whatever, they help fill out the
arrangements. So I think Phil was like, okay, great, I can get this small bouquet of the same
arrangement that I'm doing for the dinner at the restaurant. Yeah. So in Jim's defense,
当他们和鲍勃（Bob）与菲利斯（Phyllis）去高档餐厅时，所有的桌子上都摆着同样的花束。真的吗？是的。如果你去查大型活动用的廉价花卉，康乃馨和雏菊，如果你举办活动，比如婚礼什么的，它们有助于填充花束。所以我认为菲尔当时想，好吧，太棒了，我可以弄到这束小花，和我为餐厅晚餐准备的花束是一样的。是的。所以为吉姆辩护一下，
I don't know, maybe it helped out our props department. Well, I'll also have you know,
in the same scene at three minutes and 17 seconds, my grocery list is gone. So we obviously shot this on a different
day. And I've been shopping now. So in case you were worried, I got all my stuff. Michael does not
like the flowers. No. He's not a fan. He puts them on the floor. He doesn't want to see them.
I was like, you know what? I get that he doesn't want to see him. The floor, couldn't he just, like,
put him like on one of those tables behind her? I don't know. He wouldn't be able to see him.
Well, he goes up to Jim and he says, I need to have a word with you. And he says that today is a very
difficult day for many people in the office and that Pam and Jim's sexy vibes are creating a hostile
我不知道，也许这帮了我们道具组一个忙。好吧，我还得告诉你，在同一场景的3分17秒，我的购物清单不见了。所以我们显然是在不同的一天拍摄的。我现在已经买好东西了。所以如果你担心的话，我买齐了我的东西。迈克尔不喜欢这些花。不。他不是粉丝。他把它们放在地板上。他不想看到它们。我当时想，你知道吗？我明白他不想看到它们。地板上，他难道不能把它们放在她身后的那些桌子上吗？我不知道。他可能就看不到了。好吧，他走到吉姆面前说，我需要和你谈谈。他说今天对办公室里的许多人来说是非常艰难的一天，帕姆和吉姆的性感氛围正在营造一种敌对的
work environment. This whole conversation made me laugh so hard. First of all, it's kind of in hushed tones,
you know, and they're saying ridiculous things in hushed tones. That was always really hard for me.
Yeah. And when you're like, Michael, you do not get to be in our relationship.
Lady, I wrote that down because I remember making a choice to say that as if it's not the first time I've
had to explain that to Michael. It was really good. I wanted it to have history. It did. It really
paid off. Well, we had a fan question from Maddie L who says, when Michael asks Jim to have a word
with him, he starts to stand up as if he's going to head to Michael's office, but then awkwardly sits
back down when Michael chooses to sit on Jim's desk instead. Was this improvised? I think it was.
工作环境。这段对话让我笑得停不下来。首先，他们说话的声音压得很低，你知道，他们用低沉的声音说着荒谬的话。这对我来说总是很难。是的。当你像说“迈克尔，你不能介入我们的关系”时。女士，我把它记下来了，因为我记得我做了一个选择，说这句话时要表现得好像这不是我第一次不得不向迈克尔解释这一点。这真的很棒。我希望它有历史感。确实如此。它真的很有成效。好吧，我们有一个来自麦迪·L（Maddie L）的粉丝提问，她说，当迈克尔要求吉姆和他谈谈时，他开始站起来，好像要走向迈克尔的办公室，但当迈克尔选择坐在吉姆的桌子上时，他又尴尬地坐下了。这是即兴表演吗？我想是的。
I looked in the script to see if there was any stage direction. Yeah, there wasn't, except that it
clearly says they don't move into Michael's office. They stay at Jim's desk. So I think that feels like
something that John and Steve probably found in the moment. It's very funny. A hundred percent. And I feel
like those guys, you know, we've talked about this a lot. By this time, everyone knew their characters
so well. So those tops and bottoms of a scene, you could kind of play around a little bit. And it looked
like them just having fun. It's time to talk about Dwight. I feel like Dwight. How do I say?
this. I feel like this episode really shows so much of who Dwight is. There's deleted scenes where he talks
about the Blood Mobile being a vampire magnet after dark. He's ready for anything and everything,
我查了剧本，看看有没有舞台指导。是的，没有，除了明确写着他们没有移动到迈克尔的办公室。他们待在吉姆的桌子旁。所以我认为这感觉像是约翰（John）和史蒂夫（Steve）可能在当时想到的。这非常有趣。百分之百。我觉得那些家伙，你知道，我们已经谈过很多次了。到这个时候，每个人都非常了解自己的角色。所以场景的开头和结尾，你可以稍微玩一下。看起来他们只是在玩得很开心。是时候谈谈德怀特（Dwight）了。我觉得德怀特。我该怎么说呢？我觉得这一集真的展现了很多德怀特的本质。有删减片段，他谈到献血车在天黑后是吸血鬼磁铁。他为任何事情做好了准备，
you know? Yes. And he has a lot of stuff to share about how his body can do things. Yes. The nurse
is trying to take blood, but she can't find a vein. Well, you know why? He's hidden it from her.
Mm-hmm.
And when he's ready, he's going to pop it on out for her.
Yeah.
Then he has a talking head where he tells us he can also retract his penis up into himself.
He says, I train my major blood vessels to retract into my body on command.
你知道吗？是的。他有很多关于他的身体能做什么的事情要分享。是的。护士试图抽血，但找不到静脉。嗯，你知道为什么吗？他把它藏起来了。嗯哼。当他准备好时，他会把它弹出来给她。是的。然后他有一个采访镜头，告诉我们他也可以把阴茎缩回体内。是的。他说，我训练我的主要血管在指令下缩回我的身体。
Also, I can retract my penis up into itself.
We had a fan question from Robin T.
Robin, go.
Dwight's lines about retracting his blood vessels and penis is one of my favorite quotes from the entire show.
it is so absolutely absurd and hilarious and so very Dwight,
I want to know everything about this line.
Was it scripted?
How hard was it to get through?
此外，我还可以把我的阴茎缩回体内。我们有一个来自罗宾·T（Robin T）的粉丝提问。罗宾，请说。德怀特关于缩回血管和阴茎的台词是我整部剧中我最喜欢的台词之一。这绝对是荒谬而搞笑的，而且非常德怀特，我想知道关于这句台词的一切。它是写在剧本里的吗？演起来有多难？
I'll tell you, it was scripted, but this was an alternate talking head.
This is not the one that appeared in our shooting draft.
So I wasn't there when they shot it,
but I have to imagine it was very difficult to get through.
Well, it's Michael's turn to give blood, guys.
Wow, that's a big needle, he says.
Are you squeamish around needles?
I can give blood.
我告诉你，它是写在剧本里的，但这是一个备选的采访镜头。这不是出现在我们拍摄草稿中的那个。所以我拍摄时不在场，但我不得不想象演起来非常困难。好吧，轮到迈克尔献血了，伙计们。哇，那针头真大，他说。你对针头感到晕针吗？我可以献血。
I don't get faint or anything, but I don't like to watch it.
Yeah.
I don't like to see the needle going my arm.
I don't like to see the bag fill up, but I don't like it faint or weird around blood.
Yeah.
If someone's bleeding, it doesn't make me faint.
Yeah, same, same.
Okay.
我不会感到头晕什么的，但我不想看。是的。我不喜欢看到针头扎进我的手臂。我不喜欢看到血袋装满，但我不会因为血而感到头晕或奇怪。是的。如果有人流血，那不会让我晕倒。是的，一样，一样。好的。
Michael, on the other hand, is very nervous.
But luckily, there's a lovely young woman also giving blood and they start joking around.
Yes.
We asked Katie about this scene. I wanted to know, did she do any research into the process of giving blood and all of that? And here's what she had to say.
I didn't do any research for this role, but I didn't need to because my character was just nervous and pleasant. And I didn't have to dig super deep to access.
those emotions. But the funny, I do have a very funny anecdote about being nervous or my character
being nervous is that my first line was me just laughing nervously and saying, I'm so sorry,
I'm so nervous. And Steve, Steve kept cutting and he would be like, oh, no, it's okay,
另一方面，迈克尔非常紧张。但幸运的是，还有一位可爱的年轻女士也在献血，他们开始开玩笑。是的。我们问了凯蒂（Katie）关于这个场景的问题。我想知道，她是否对献血的过程做了任何研究？她是这么说的。我没有为这个角色做任何研究，但我不需要，因为我的角色只是紧张而愉快。我不需要深入挖掘就能触及那些情绪。但是有趣的是，我有一个关于紧张或者我的角色紧张的非常有趣的轶事，那就是我的第一句台词就是我紧张地笑着说，我很抱歉，我太紧张了。史蒂夫，史蒂夫一直喊停，他会说，哦，不，没关系，
we'll go again. We'll go again. And finally, I was just like, I think.
I think it's my line. I think that's what I'm supposed to say. But that has always made me laugh. And of course, yes, I was thrilled to work with Steve. To get that, to get the show was its own triumph. But then to have my scene be with him was just like I was over the moon.
I love that story about Steve. Because he was such a caretaker like that. He would want our guest actors to feel really comfortable.
And, you know, he'd be like, oh, no, it's okay.
We'll start again.
We'll wait till you're comfortable.
I was like, no, it's actually my line.
I would also be relieved if the first time I ever had to be in a scene with Steve,
我们再来一次。我们再来一次。最后，我只是说，我想。我想这是我的台词。我想这就是我应该说的。但这总是让我发笑。当然，是的，我很高兴能和史蒂夫合作。能得到这个角色本身就是一种胜利。但能和他在同一个场景里演戏，就像我欣喜若狂一样。我喜欢关于史蒂夫的那个故事。因为他就像那样一个照顾者。他会希望我们的客串演员感到非常舒适。而且，你知道，他会说，哦，不，没关系。我们重新开始。我们等到你舒服为止。我当时想，不，这其实是我的台词。如果我第一次和史蒂夫演对手戏，我也会感到如释重负，
I got to just laugh nervously and say I was nervous.
Yes.
Because it would be so truthful.
Such an honest moment.
Yeah.
There's a third person in this scene.
It's the nurse.
She was great.
我只需要紧张地笑笑，说我很紧张。是的。因为那会非常真实。如此诚实的时刻。是的。这个场景里还有第三个人。是护士。她很棒。
I wondered if she was a real bloodmobile nurse since that was a real bloodmobile.
Yeah, and she seemed kind of no nonsense, like very comfortable.
Well, she was, in fact, an actress.
Her name is Julie Ramallah.
She has not been on Monk or Law and Order,
but she was on several episodes of The Young and the Restless,
as well as many movies and TV shows.
Well, Michael's going to make the mistake of looking at his blood bag.
我想知道她是否真的是献血车的护士，因为那是一辆真正的献血车。是的，她看起来有点干练，非常自在。嗯，她实际上是一位演员。她的名字叫朱莉·拉马拉（Julie Ramallah）。她没有演过《神探阿蒙》（Monk）或《法律与秩序》（Law and Order），但她出演过几集《年轻和骚动不安的一族》（The Young and the Restless），以及许多电影和电视剧。好吧，迈克尔要犯一个错误，去看他的血袋。
He freaks out a little, and he says to her,
tell me story, say something, distract me.
And she says he's cute.
And he's, I think, so happy.
And then he shares it he didn't eat for three days
because he was so nervous about giving blood and he passes out.
Yes.
We had a fan question.
他有点吓坏了，他对她说，给我讲个故事，说点什么，分散我的注意力。她说他很可爱。我想他非常高兴。然后他分享说他三天没吃东西了，因为他太紧张了，不敢献血，然后他就晕倒了。是的。我们有一个粉丝提问。
Many, many people wanted to know how do we do these scenes of people giving blood?
Some people wanted to know, did they actually give blood?
No.
Oh, my goodness.
You know.
Not in the episode.
Yes, the next day, but not while we were filming.
很多人都想知道我们是怎么拍摄这些献血场景的？有些人想知道，他们真的献血了吗？不。哦，天哪。不。你知道的。不是在这一集里。是的，第二天，但不是在我们拍摄的时候。
The next day with trained professionals and not actors pretending to take blood.
Correct.
I found out how they make faky blood.
Oh.
Thanks to Randy Cordray.
How do they do it?
All right.
It's a combination of water, food coloring, and you're not going to believe it.
第二天由训练有素的专业人员，而不是假装抽血的演员。没错。我发现了他们是怎么制作假血的。哦。多亏了兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）。他们是怎么做的？好吧。它是水、食用色素的混合物，你绝对不会相信。
One more thing.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
You'll never guess.
Wait, wait, wait, I want to try a guess.
You can eat it.
I thought you could eat it.
I was going to say like jello.
Nestle's quick.
还有一件事。等等，等等，等等，等等。你永远猜不到。等等，等等，我想试着猜一下。你可以吃它。我以为你可以吃它。我本来想说像果冻一样。雀巢速溶巧克力粉。
Oh. Yeah. That thickens it a little, I guess.
Yeah. So our blood was all made by our special effects team led by Ron Neri.
Hmm. Had to make faky blood that day. Faky blood. Well, I thought the reveal of Hank when Michael comes to, it was one of the best moments. I laughed so hard. It was so perfect.
And then he calls the nurse a waitress. He's like so out of it. And he finds her glove. He does. And this starts his whole mission.
to find her.
To return the glove.
Yeah.
Like Cinderella's slipper.
哦。是的。我想这会让它变稠一点。是的。所以我们的血都是由罗恩·内里（Ron Neri）领导的特效团队制作的。嗯。那天必须制作假血。假血。好吧，我觉得迈克尔醒来时看到汉克（Hank）的那个揭示是最好的时刻之一。我笑得太厉害了。太完美了。然后他管护士叫女服务员。他当时神志不清。他发现了她的手套。他确实发现了。这开启了他寻找她的整个任务。为了归还手套。是的。就像灰姑娘的水晶鞋。
I know.
It's really cute.
We have one more clip from Katie where she just shares her memories of her time on the show.
I asked her, anything, stick out to you.
And Angela, wait until you hear what she says.
Oh, I can't wait.
I don't remember a ton of details about my time on set, except for that you guys were on your last day of.
like a very, very, very long cycle of shooting, and everyone was just dead, tired and just
我知道。这真的很可爱。我们还有一段凯蒂的片段，她分享了她在剧组的记忆。我问她，有什么突出的事情吗？安吉拉，等着听她说的话。哦，我等不及了。我不记得我在片场的时间里的很多细节，除了你们当时正处于拍摄一个非常、非常、非常长的周期的最后一天，每个人都累得要死，而且只是
ready for a hiatus. So that is what I remember, but they were lovely. Everyone was great,
but just like the talk was all about how this hiatus was just so needed. So that's what I remember. So that's what I remember.
that and that you guys moved so quickly. It was like the fastest. I don't even know if I got lunch
that day. Like I showed up. I did my scene and I'm pretty sure you guys banged me out and I didn't even
get a free lunch. All right. This was, remember early on? We had to do 18 episodes in a row so that we
could create that hiatus for Steve to go to a movie. Yeah. This was that 18th episode. We were so
wiped. Yep. 18 weeks of 12 to 14 hour days. Yeah. And you guys, you know when you have that
stretch of work where you leave work and it's dark out and then you come back to work and it's still
准备好休假了。这就是我记得的，但他们很可爱。每个人都很棒，只是谈话内容都是关于这次休假是多么必要。这就是我记得的。这就是我记得的。还有就是你们动作太快了。就像最快的一样。我甚至不知道那天我有没有吃午饭。就像我出现了。我演了我的场景，我很确定你们把我搞定了，我甚至没得到一顿免费午餐。好吧。这是，记得早期吗？我们不得不连续拍摄18集，这样我们才能为史蒂夫去拍电影创造那个休假。是的。这就是第18集。我们太累了。是的。18周，每天12到14小时。是的。你们知道当你有一段工作时间，你离开工作时天是黑的，然后你回到工作时天依然
dark out. You know what I mean? Because you're there so early. Yeah. And you're just like,
and you sort of all look at each other and joke and be like, see you in a few hours. There's a
whole thing now. It's called clopening. Clopening. And it's a lot of people who work in the service
industry or in the food industry where you have to close the restaurant and then like a few hours later you have to open it.
Yeah.
Clopening.
Well, we were in the clopening phase.
是黑的。你知道我的意思吗？因为你来得太早了。是的。你们只是，你们会互相看着对方开玩笑说，几个小时后再见。现在有一个专门的词。叫“clopening”（关门后开门）。Clopening。很多在服务行业或食品行业工作的人，必须关掉餐厅，然后几个小时后又必须开门。是的。Clopening。Clopening。好吧，我们当时处于clopening阶段。
We were.
That is hilarious to me because I do remember like when we would wrap after a big stretch like that, I would get like a cold.
I would get sick.
We talked about that.
Yeah.
Right now we were about to all get sick.
Basically.
我们确实是。这对我来说太搞笑了，因为我确实记得当我们结束这样一段长时间的工作后，我会感冒。我会生病。我们谈过那个。是的。当时我们都快要生病了。是的。基本上。
And Katie clocked it and has remembered it all these years later.
That's how tired we were.
We were so tired.
Next up is a scene I'm dying to talk about.
It's in the conference room.
Kelly and Meredith are decorating for the Lonely Hearts Party.
Is this a good time to talk about how Meredith is wearing the vest again?
Yes.
凯蒂注意到了这一点，并且多年来一直记得。我们当时就是那么累。我们太累了。接下来是一个我迫不及待想谈论的场景。在会议室里。凯利（Kelly）和梅雷迪思（Meredith）正在为“孤独之心派对”做装饰。现在是谈论梅雷迪思为什么又穿那件背心的时候了吗？是的。
The sweater vest.
It is making its second appearance in the series pretty quickly because it was just in the duel.
Yes, this is the vest that I wore to a press event with John Krasinski.
And by the way, it was not Betsy Johnson.
It was Nanette Lapoor.
Fancy.
and Meredith loves it clearly and is wearing it again.
They were really, I think, rubbing it in my face.
那件毛衣背心。它在剧集中很快就第二次出现了，因为它刚在“决斗”那一集中出现过。是的，这就是我和约翰·卡拉辛斯基（John Krasinski）参加新闻发布会时穿的背心。顺便说一句，那不是贝齐·约翰逊（Betsy Johnson）。那是娜内特·勒波尔（Nanette Lepore）。时髦。梅雷迪思显然很喜欢它，又穿上了它。我想他们真的是在往我脸上抹黑。
I take it personally.
I'm kidding.
Well, there's something happening now that I as an actor am super jealous of
because Jim and Pam are going to go to frickin' lunch with Bob and Phyllis.
Jenna, I would have loved to been there.
That looked like so much fun.
And I love it.
It's like the thing we talk about when random characters get thrown together.
我把它当成个人的事了。开个玩笑。好吧，现在发生了一件事，作为演员我超级嫉妒，因为吉姆和帕姆要和鲍勃与菲利斯去吃午饭了。珍娜（Jenna），我真希望当时也在那里。那看起来太有趣了。我喜欢它。就像我们谈论随机角色被凑在一起时发生的事情。
what's going to happen, what's the chemistry.
I lived for every scene.
And there was so much more in the script,
and there's more in the deleted scenes.
Phyllis and I were so excited for this storyline.
We're the two St. Louis gals.
Yeah.
And we got to have this whole day of shooting together.
会发生什么，化学反应是什么。我为每一个场景而活。剧本里还有很多内容，删减片段里也有更多。菲利斯和我对这个故事情节感到非常兴奋。我们是两个圣路易斯的姑娘。是的。我们得以一起度过了整个拍摄日。
We got to talk about bowling.
Yes.
We had a fan question from Joe S.
Where were the restaurant scenes for the double date filmed?
I will tell you.
They were filmed at a real restaurant called Barsack Brasier.
It was on Lancashem Boulevard in North Hollywood.
We filled the restaurant with background performers who were pretending to be servers and diners.
我们谈论了保龄球。是的。我们有一个来自乔·S（Joe S）的粉丝提问。双重约会的餐厅场景是在哪里拍摄的？我来告诉你。它们是在一家名为Barsack Brasier的真实餐厅拍摄的。它位于北好莱坞的兰开夏大道（Lancashem Boulevard）。我们用假装是服务员和食客的背景演员填满了餐厅。
We had the restaurant for half a day.
It is no longer in business, but that's where we were.
And we ate their real food.
Well, if you look at the tables, there you're going to see, Jim's bouquet of flowers to Pam on every table.
I'll do a side by side in our stories.
And I want to ask you, Jenna, about the scene with the bowling.
Okay.
All right.
我们用了半天时间拍摄那家餐厅。它现在已经倒闭了，但那就是我们当时所在的地方。我们吃了他们真正的食物。好吧，如果你看那些桌子，你会看到，吉姆送给帕姆的花束在每一张桌子上都有。我会在我们的故事里做一个对比图。我想问你，珍娜，关于保龄球的那个场景。好的。好吧。
So Bob says, everyone here who's bowled at 280, please raise your hand.
And you guys are like super impressed.
Yeah.
What's the highest bowling number?
300.
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah.
That's a big deal.
所以鲍勃说，这里所有打过280分的人，请举手。你们看起来超级印象深刻。是的。保龄球的最高分是多少？300。哦，天哪。是的。那是个大数字。
I don't know a lot about bowling.
I don't know much about bowling.
Yes.
300 is if you get a strike in every frame.
Wowzers.
Okay.
Well, there was a whole other storyline where clearly the writers wanted Jim and Pam to be impressed by
How cool Bob and Phyllis were.
我对保龄球了解不多。我对保龄球了解不多。是的。300分意味着你在每一局都打出全中。哇哦。好的。好吧，还有另一个故事情节，显然编剧们希望吉姆和帕姆对鲍勃和菲利斯有多酷留下深刻印象。
There was a whole other scene where you guys talk about how you went to Dave Matthews band.
Yes, I remember shooting it.
And that they had great seats and that Phyllis like went backstage and all this stuff.
Yeah, we're like, oh my gosh, Bob and Phyllis are kind of cool.
And then they excuse themselves to the restroom.
We got some mail from Emily Y who really appreciated the callback from Phyllis's wedding about Phyllis being a good bowler.
Oh, yeah.
I also enjoyed that.
还有另一个场景，你们谈论了你们是如何去看戴夫·马修斯乐队（Dave Matthews band）的。是的，我记得拍摄那个场景。他们有很棒的座位，菲利斯去了后台之类的。是的，我们当时想，哦，天哪，鲍勃和菲利斯真酷。然后他们借口去洗手间。我们收到了一封来自艾米丽·Y（Emily Y）的邮件，她非常欣赏关于菲利斯擅长打保龄球的那个呼应。哦，是的。我也很喜欢那个。
If you guys remember, Bob has a speech at their reception where he refers to Phyllis as, quote, a hell of a bowler.
That's right.
I think we should take a break before we go to Michael's Lonely Hearts party.
I do, too.
Is that okay?
I think we should, too.
Before we go to break, I just want to say one thing.
What is it?
如果你们还记得，鲍勃在他们的招待会上有一个演讲，他称菲利斯为“一个了不起的保龄球手”。没错。我想在我们去迈克尔的“孤独之心派对”之前，我们应该休息一下。我也这么认为。可以吗？我想我们也应该这样。在休息之前，我只想说一件事。是什么？
That I love that Bob says, I don't know how you work with that one jackass and then that new jackass and that other jackass.
Yeah, and Phyllis is like, he.
He means Michael Dwight and Andy.
And Jim's like, oh, I knew who he was talking about.
I know, I know.
All right.
Let's go to break.
We are back, and since I shared about my hot feet today, I thought I would also share about another wardrobe malfunction that I discovered during my bathroom break, which is that I put my underwear on inside out today.
我喜欢鲍勃说，“我不知道你怎么和那个混蛋一起工作，还有那个新混蛋，以及那个别的混蛋。”是的，菲利斯说，他指的是迈克尔、德怀特和安迪。吉姆说，哦，我知道他在说谁。我知道，我知道。好吧。我们去休息吧。我们回来了，既然我今天分享了关于我脚热的事，我想我也分享一下我在上厕所时发现的另一个服装故障，那就是我今天把内裤穿反了。
Oh.
I'm having that day, everybody.
I think I look really put together.
today. Do I? Or is it, no? You know, you didn't say yes. In fact, well, you've got to look on your face like,
how do I say this? I, you know what? You know why? I don't want you to move. Don't move. Don't move. I just
want to take a picture of your hair and then I'm going to answer. Okay. Now you just said,
I feel pretty, pretty put together today. Now I want you to look at this. Okay. Okay.
Now your outfit, lady, it's all happening. You have your little shirt and pants and your fancy sneakers.
哦。大家，我今天就是这样。我觉得我今天看起来真的很得体。是吗？还是，不？你知道，你没说“是”。事实上，嗯，你的表情好像在说，我该怎么说呢？我，你知道吗？你知道为什么吗？我不想让你动。别动。别动。我只是想拍一张你头发的照片，然后我会回答。好的。现在你刚才说，我觉得今天穿得很得体。现在我想让你看看这个。好的。好的。现在你的装扮，女士，一切都在发生。你有你的小衬衫、裤子和时髦的运动鞋。
I like your look today. Good. Okay. Okay. All right. Let's go to the lonely hearts party.
Let's do because Michael wants to go around and have everyone tell their worst relationship story.
Michael has this way of like, oh, you don't feel good. I want you to feel worse.
Yeah. I think he thinks this is going to be, I don't know, bonding.
cathartic?
Well, you guys, we had to sit in a circle facing each other.
We could not get through these scenes.
We each went around and said the most ridiculous things.
我喜欢你今天的造型。很好。好的。好的。好吧。我们去“孤独之心派对”吧。让我们开始吧，因为迈克尔想四处走动，让每个人都讲出他们最糟糕的恋爱故事。迈克尔有这种方式，比如，哦，你感觉不好。我想让你感觉更糟。是的。我想他认为这会是，我不知道，建立联系？宣泄？好吧，伙计们，我们不得不围成一圈面对面坐着。我们无法演完这些场景。我们每个人轮流说出最荒谬的事情。
There was way more than what you're seeing here.
There was more on the page.
And we just were laughing all day.
Also, for the supporting cast, we got to have Steve all to ourselves and interact with
him and as Michael Scott and our characters.
And it just was a freaking hilariously fun afternoon.
I love how Oscar doesn't want to share, and then he clearly has been going on and on.
Yeah, it actually in the script starts with Meredith, and she talks about the woman her husband left her for.
这里发生的事情远不止你看到的这些。剧本里还有更多内容。我们整天都在笑。另外，对于配角，我们能独享史蒂夫，并以迈克尔·斯科特和我们角色的身份与他互动。那真是一个超级搞笑、有趣的下午。我喜欢奥斯卡不想分享的样子，然后他显然已经说个没完了。是的，剧本里其实是从梅雷迪思开始的，她谈到了她丈夫为了那个女人而抛弃了她。
I think we need to hear some of it.
So.
My husband ran off with some broad.
Who is she?
She was our garbage woman.
Nice.
I totally get it.
I mean, she was strong.
我想我们需要听听其中的一些内容。所以。我丈夫跟一个荡妇跑了。她是谁？她是我们的垃圾清理工。不错。我完全理解。我是说，她很强壮。
She had a career.
She could heave a bag of garbage.
as high as a two-story house.
So sorry, Marita.
My kids call her mom now.
I guess it's for the best.
Oh, my God.
她有份工作。她能把一袋垃圾举得像两层楼那么高。真抱歉，玛丽塔。我的孩子们现在叫她妈妈。我想这是最好的结果。天哪。天哪。
Okay.
All right.
Well, let's, who else?
Kids!
She said, my kids.
I know.
More evidence that there's more than one.
好吧。好的。那么，还有谁？孩子们！她说，我的孩子们。我知道。我知道。这进一步证明了不止一个。
More evidence.
And then I don't know if you heard at the end,
Steve as Michael goes, oh, God, okay.
Like, every time he did that after everyone's story.
It was so hard to keep it together.
Michael tries to get Kelly to share, but she insists that I guess her heart wasn't broken,
that Ryan's okay, that his heart was in the right place.
Michael reminds her that his heart and body are now in Thailand having random sex.
进一步证明。然后我不知道你有没有听到最后，史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔说，哦，天哪，好吧。就像他在每个人的故事之后都那样做一样。真的很难忍住不笑。迈克尔试图让凯莉分享，但她坚持认为，我想她的心并没有碎，瑞安没问题，他的心在正确的地方。迈克尔提醒她，他的心和身体现在都在泰国，正在进行随意的性行为。
Awesome.
Again, great pep talk, Michael.
Angela had a talking head here.
It's in the deleted scenes.
I want to play it, Jenna, because I then want to read you what was.
was my alt talking head. Because we talk a lot about how our alternate talking heads sometimes
would just be all over the map. And I want you to hear the difference. Okay, play what would have
actually ended up in the episode if we had had more time. I do not have a Valentine this year.
太棒了。再说一次，很棒的鼓励，迈克尔。安吉拉在这里有一个采访镜头。它在删减片段里。我想播放它，珍娜，因为我想读给你听听我的备选采访镜头是什么。因为我们经常谈论我们的备选采访镜头有时会多么天马行空。我想让你听听区别。好的，播放如果我们有更多时间，原本会出现在剧集里的内容。我今年没有情人。
I recently got out of two long-term relationships. So I want to wait before I do that again.
Okay, so that's what we shot. Okay. Amazing. Amazing. Here was my alt. One of my alt's guys.
The major holidays are Christmas, Easter, and the 4th of July.
Valentine's Day is bullshit.
And then they said, we could try it this way.
Valentine's Day is bullpucky.
Ah.
But that was my alt.
我最近结束了两段长期关系。所以我不想在再次开始之前就那样做。好吧，这就是我们拍摄的内容。好吧。太棒了。太棒了。这是我的备选。我的备选之一。主要的节日是圣诞节、复活节和7月4日。情人节是胡扯。然后他们说，我们可以试试这种方式。情人节是胡说八道。啊。但那是我的备选。
Well, Angela does share her, I guess, heartbreak story, which is that there was a time when she was in a relationship with two men, both of whom she loved, and they ended up dueling over.
her. And Oscar's like, we know we were there, Dwight and Andy. And she's like, no, this was years
ago when I was living in Ohio, John Mark, and John David. Ohio! I know. John Mark and John David.
What was her other life? And then Oscar's like, wait a second, you had two sets of different men
actually dole over you. And I had so much fun saying, I guess I have. Huh. And then your deleted
talking head implies that you might do this a third time, but you need a moment. I need a moment.
Before you do that again.
Again.
嗯，安吉拉确实分享了她的，我想是心碎的故事，那就是有一次她同时和两个男人谈恋爱，她都爱他们，最后他们为了她决斗了。奥斯卡说，我们知道，我们在场，德怀特和安迪。她说，不，那是几年前我住在俄亥俄州的时候，约翰·马克和约翰·大卫。俄亥俄州！我知道。约翰·马克和约翰·大卫。她的另一段生活是什么？然后奥斯卡说，等等，你竟然有两组不同的男人为你决斗。我说“我想我有”的时候觉得太有趣了。嗯。然后你被删减的采访镜头暗示你可能会第三次这样做，但你需要一点时间。我需要一点时间。在你再次这样做之前。再次。
And then, you guys, Oscar's whole story was so great.
There was so much more to it.
I wish it hadn't been cut.
He talks about, like, the whole entire way he met this guy and how it all played out.
And it really builds.
And we're hanging on his every word.
And a lot of that had to be cut for time.
But it was really fun to shoot.
还有，伙计们，奥斯卡的整个故事太棒了。里面还有更多内容。我真希望它没被剪掉。他谈到了他遇见那个人的整个过程以及事情是如何发展的。它真的很有层次。我们都在仔细聆听他的每一句话。但为了时间，很多内容不得不被剪掉。但拍摄过程真的很有趣。
We also find out where Andy is.
Because, guys, he has not been in this episode at all.
Where is he?
he is on his honeymoons.
Yeah, Oscar said, you know, he had to put full deposits down that he couldn't get back,
non-refundables, on these honeymoon.
So he's just going and doing them all.
He's got a hot air balloon thing, a massage.
我们还发现了安迪在哪里。因为，伙计们，他根本没出现在这一集里。他在哪儿？他在度蜜月。是的，奥斯卡说，你知道，他必须支付全额押金，而且是不可退还的，这些蜜月旅行他拿不回来。所以他干脆就去把它们都完成了。他有热气球项目，还有按摩。
Lady, this got me thinking, how many times does this happen?
Do people share about this where they had an engagement that got broken off and they've already paid for the honeymoon and who goes on it?
I guess it happens quite a bit.
I know someone it happened to.
You do?
What was the honeymoon destination?
I think the honeymoon destination was Hawaii.
And what they did was they each, like, canceled their plane ticket, and they got the credit.
天哪，这让我开始思考，这种情况发生了多少次？人们会分享这种事吗，就是订婚取消了，但已经付了蜜月旅行的钱，谁会去呢？我想这种情况经常发生。我认识一个人就遇到过。你认识？蜜月目的地是哪儿？我想蜜月目的地是夏威夷。他们做的是，每个人都取消了自己的机票，然后拿到了退款额度。
And my friend came and visited me on what would have been her honeymoon week.
Wow.
So instead of flying to Hawaii, she rerouted it to L.A., and then I took her to Laguna Beach,
and we just hung out the week that it would have been her honeymoon.
Oh my gosh, you have such a personal story about this.
Well, in my search online about these stories, guess what I found?
What?
In March of 2019, the New York Times ran an article saying that traveling alone for your honeymoon
我的朋友在我本该是她蜜月周的时候来看我。哇。所以她没有飞往夏威夷，而是改道去了洛杉矶，然后我带她去了拉古纳海滩，我们就在本该是她蜜月的那一周待在一起。天哪，你竟然有关于这件事的亲身经历。嗯，在我上网搜索这些故事时，你猜我发现了什么？什么？2019年3月，《纽约时报》刊登了一篇文章，说独自去度蜜月
is actually on trend.
What?
Yeah, I know.
I'm sorry, wait, but the marriage happened.
The marriage happened.
And then you go by yourself on a honeymoon trip?
You both go separately by yourself.
They said it's been given too.
实际上是一种趋势。什么？是的，我知道。抱歉，等等，但是婚姻已经发生了。婚姻已经发生了。然后你独自去度蜜月？你们俩分别独自去。他们说它甚至被赋予了。
nicknames, solo moons are unymoons. And according to Jessica Carbino, who's an online dating expert,
and a sociologist for the dating app Bumble, she says, frankly, the idea of separate honeymoons
may signal the continued evolution of marriage. Given the recognition that for most couples
today, marriage and partnership is considered all-consuming with the partner needing to fulfill
every role, physical, spiritual, emotional, and sexual, perhaps separate vacations is a recognition
among some couples that all expectations cannot be met by a single person. This caused a stir on
Twitter. Well, look at my face. I know, this whole article. So Helen Fisher from the Kinsey Institute,
guys, I'm not related, but, you know, same last name. Helen Fisher, who works at the Kinsey Institute
昵称，单人蜜月或非蜜月。根据在线约会专家、约会软件Bumble的社会学家杰西卡·卡比诺的说法，她说，坦率地说，单独度蜜月的想法可能标志着婚姻的持续演变。考虑到当今大多数夫妇都认识到，婚姻和伴侣关系被认为是全方位的，伴侣需要满足每一个角色，身体、精神、情感和性，也许单独度假是某些夫妇的一种认识，即单一的人无法满足所有期望。这在推特上引起了轰动。好吧，看看我的脸。我知道，整篇文章。所以金赛研究所的海伦·费舍尔，伙计们，我跟她没亲戚关系，但你知道，姓氏一样。在金赛研究所工作的海伦·费舍尔
said, perhaps I'm old-fashioned, but I think it should be marked. You're at a new stage,
your life when you marry and you are missing out on triggering the three most valuable brain systems
for a lasting relationship. I'm with this. Same. Like, oh my gosh, you just got married. This is a
celebration of your union. Isn't the whole idea to go take a trip together? Yeah, I just think it's a
milestone that is best celebrated together. I know. I mean, I do see the value in once you are married,
And especially if you have kids, there is a great restorative, wonderful indulgence if you can take a trip solo, right?
I mean, my dream vacation is me going and sleeping somewhere for three days, you know?
So, yes, sign me up.
说，也许我很老派，但我认为它应该被标记出来。当你结婚时，你处于人生的一个新阶段，如果你错过了触发持久关系中最有价值的三个大脑系统的机会，那很可惜。我同意这一点。我也是。就像，天哪，你刚结婚。这是对你们结合的庆祝。难道整个想法不是一起去旅行吗？是的，我只是认为这是一个最好一起庆祝的里程碑。我知道。我是说，我确实看到了结婚后的价值，特别是如果你有孩子的话，如果你能独自去旅行，那是一种非常恢复元气、美妙的放纵，对吧？我是说，我梦想的假期就是我去某个地方睡上三天，你知道吗？所以，是的，算我一个。
But when you first get married.
But you've also been married a long time and you have young children and the idea of getting to sleep in.
No, I've been married over 11 years.
And yes, I'm thinking, what solo vacation?
I mean, even now, if there's a chance that we could have someone watch our kids,
I'd want to go somewhere with Lee for three days.
We could just sleep.
I know.
但当你刚结婚时。但你也结婚很久了，你有年幼的孩子，想到可以睡懒觉。不，我已经结婚超过11年了。是的，我在想，什么单独度假？我是说，即使现在，如果有机会能找人看孩子，我也想和李去某个地方待三天。我们可以只睡觉。我知道。
I think he'd like it too.
I get excited when Josh and I can both run errands at the same time together.
Yes.
If I turn to him.
That's sometimes a date night for us.
It is.
Like, if I turned to him and say, I got to go to Target and he's like, oh, I can go to.
I'm like, no way.
我想他也会喜欢的。当乔什和我能同时一起去办杂事时，我会很兴奋。是的。如果我转向他。那有时对我们来说就是约会之夜。确实。就像，如果我转向他说，我得去塔吉特百货，他会说，哦，我也能去。我会说，太棒了。
I'm so excited.
I hear all of that.
Here's the thing.
I'll just say it.
I like to be around my husband all the time.
We don't even have to be talking to each other.
I like to text him all day.
I like to get his texts.
我太兴奋了。我听到了所有这些。事情是这样的。我就直说了。我喜欢一直待在我丈夫身边。我们甚至不需要互相交谈。我喜欢整天给他发短信。我喜欢收到他的短信。
I mean, I don't know.
I like him.
I know.
I want to go on honeymoon with him.
I want to go to honeymoon with my person.
Anyway, so Andy is on sort of a sad unymoon.
Well, I'll tell you where he really was.
我是说，我不知道。我喜欢他。我知道。我想和他一起去度蜜月。我知道。我想和我的那个人去度蜜月。总之，安迪正在进行某种悲伤的单人蜜月。好吧，我会告诉你他真正去了哪里。
Oh, where Ed Helms was.
Yes, Ed was filming the hangover in Las Vegas.
Oh, that's right.
This is when we had the crazy schedule for him.
He was so tired, Jenna.
He was.
Do you remember he would get off the plane from Vegas and come straight to our set?
Yeah.
哦，埃德·赫尔姆斯去了哪里。是的，埃德当时正在拉斯维加斯拍摄《宿醉》。哦，对了。这就是我们为他安排疯狂日程的时候。他太累了，珍娜。他确实很累。你还记得他会从拉斯维加斯的飞机上下来，直接来到我们的片场吗？是的。
Here's what we did.
It was this big negotiation between the studios.
He would be on set with us Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday.
We only got him three days.
Right.
Then he would fly after work and start work on the hangover.
Friday, Saturday, Sunday, Monday.
He was working seven days, but there were two weeks when he had to work on the hangover all week,
我们是这样做的。这是工作室之间的一次大谈判。他周二、周三、周四会在片场和我们在一起。我们只有他三天。对。然后他会在下班后飞走，开始拍摄《宿醉》。周五、周六、周日、周一。他一周工作七天，但有两周他必须整周拍摄《宿醉》，
and this was one of those weeks.
Remember, BJ was also gone right now filming Inglorious Bastards, so two of our fellows were off making movies.
So they created these storylines for these guys so that they could do their movies.
They got very creative with this idea of Andy being on his honeymoons, because after this episode aired,
NBC uploaded photos of Ed pretending to be on vacation.
They put him in the Angela Martin, Andy Bernard wedding website.
They had him pose and all these different outfits in front of a green screen.
They had him scuba diving, standing in front of a hot air balloon in Napa Valley, and visiting Epcot Center.
这就是其中一周。记住，BJ当时也离开了，去拍摄《无耻混蛋》，所以我们的两个伙伴都去拍电影了。所以他们为这些人创造了这些故事情节，以便他们能去拍电影。他们在这个关于安迪去度蜜月的想法上非常有创意，因为在这一集播出后，NBC上传了埃德假装在度假的照片。他们把他放进了安吉拉·马丁和安迪·伯纳德的婚礼网站。他们让他穿着各种不同的服装在绿幕前摆姿势。他们让他潜水，站在纳帕谷的热气球前，还参观了艾波卡特中心。
I think I might still have those.
I found the one of him in front of the balloon.
Yeah.
And I also found the message that they wrote from Andy.
to everyone on the wedding website. It said this. Quote,
Wanted all my bros and bras and cyberspace to know that the old nard dog is doing just fine.
Back to our group of sadness, Kevin is going to share about his breakup from Stacey.
Yeah.
我想我可能还有那些照片。我找到了他在热气球前的那张。是的。我还找到了安迪在婚礼网站上写给每个人的留言。上面写着这个。引用，“想让我在网络空间的所有兄弟姐妹们知道，老纳德狗一切都好。”回到我们悲伤的群体，凯文要分享他与斯泰西的分手。是的。
Michael decides to become a problem solver. He says there's got to be a way to get all the lonely people together.
A mixer. First, Dwight says, a giant net.
Jenna, I thought that that was an improv.
And I went and looked in the script and it was completely 100% written.
It's so funny.
But no, you're right.
Michael is saying a mixer, aka an old-fashioned meat market.
迈克尔决定成为一个问题解决者。他说一定有一种方法能把所有孤独的人聚在一起。联谊会。首先，德怀特说，一张巨大的网。珍娜，我以为那是即兴表演。我去查了剧本，发现它是百分之百写好的。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。但不，你是对的。迈克尔说的是联谊会，也就是老式的肉类市场。
Mm-hmm.
They're going to put up flyers.
Yep.
They're going to invite people and on the flyer.
Michael is going to make sure that he is, you know, sending out a beacon to this lost glove lady.
Yeah.
And he says, you know what?
Cupid is going to shoot his spare roll.
嗯哼。他们要贴传单。是的。他们要邀请人们，在传单上。迈克尔要确保他，你知道，向这位丢失手套的女士发出信号。是的。他说，你知道吗？丘比特要射出他的麻雀。
at unsuspecting victims.
Yeah.
His sparrow.
A funny little bird, but he gets the job done.
That's right.
That tickled me because I feel like I get phrases one or two words off.
You feel like it?
You do.
射向毫无防备的受害者。是的。他的麻雀。一只滑稽的小鸟，但他完成了任务。没错。这让我觉得很有趣，因为我觉得我总是把短语说错一两个词。你觉得吗？你确实。
Why is Sam applauding?
Oh, my gosh.
Because we thought the same thing when you said it.
Like there's a debate to it.
I feel like it might be possible.
That in this moment, I really relate.
to Michael.
你确实。为什么萨姆在鼓掌？哦，天哪。因为当你这么说的时候，我们想到了同样的事情。就像对此有争议一样。我觉得这可能是可能的。在这一刻，我真的很有共鸣。对迈克尔。
When the mixer gets underway, two women enter.
Yes, Lynn and Rhee.
Rie was played by Tate Hanyak.
She's done a ton of comedy television work,
everything from Scrubs, Community Superstore.
She has been on Monk.
And I can't believe I'm going to say this.
What?
当联谊会开始时，两个女人进来了。是的，琳恩和瑞。瑞由泰特·汉亚克饰演。她做了大量的喜剧电视工作，从《实习医生风云》、《废柴联盟》到《超市特工》。她还上过《神探阿蒙》。我不敢相信我要说这个。什么？
I was so excited.
What?
She has been.
John Wick.
No.
Oh.
I've seen John Wick.
What?
我太兴奋了。什么？她上过。疾速追杀。不。哦。我看过《疾速追杀》。什么？
With Keanu Reeves?
How does she know them? What?
No. Oh, my gosh. You are so on Keanu today.
No, she was in a television pilot called Hummingbird.
Oh, my Lord. I should just know today all of your anecdotes are hummingbird related.
I mean, I couldn't believe it when I was looking her up. She played Sienna.
The series was a thriller about a young girl who vanishes.
Hmm.
和基努·里维斯一起？她怎么认识他们？什么？不。哦，天哪。你今天真是满脑子都是基努。不，她出演了一部名为《蜂鸟》的电视试播集。哦，天哪。我今天应该知道你所有的轶事都和蜂鸟有关。我是说，当我查她的时候，我简直不敢相信。她饰演西耶娜。该系列是一部关于一个年轻女孩失踪的惊悚片。嗯。
The other lady who has entered is Lynn.
Mm-hmm.
She was played by Lisa K. Wyatt.
this is her first of four episodes.
Yes.
She's going to become a love interest for Kevin.
In addition to her numerous film television commercial credits,
such as Donnie Darko, Legally Blonde, and Days of Our Lives,
进来的另一位女士是琳恩。嗯哼。她由丽莎·K·怀亚特饰演。这是她四集中的第一集。是的。她将成为凯文的恋爱对象。除了她众多的电影、电视和商业广告作品，如《死亡幻觉》、《律政俏佳人》和《我们的日子》，
Lisa Wyatt also does stand up.
And along with her husband, she coaches other actors in an acting technique,
acting technique, called the Mechanics of Believability at the Acting Garage in Los Angeles.
I thought she was very believable.
There you go.
Spot on.
Did you guys all notice that Rhee is dressed like Angela Martin?
Yes, we got mail about it.
丽莎·怀亚特还做单口喜剧。她和她的丈夫一起，在洛杉矶的Acting Garage指导其他演员一种表演技巧，叫“可信度机制”。我觉得她非常可信。就是这样。完全正确。你们都注意到瑞的打扮像安吉拉·马丁了吗？是的，我们收到了关于此的邮件。
People wanted to know if that was on purpose.
I think so, yes.
Yes, I think so.
Mm-hmm.
Yes.
Well, Michael's going to bring Lynn right on over to Kevin.
He wants to make a love connection.
I mean, Michael's playing Cupid.
人们想知道那是不是故意的。我想是的，是的。是的，我想是的。嗯哼。是的。好吧，迈克尔要把琳恩带到凯文那里。他想促成一段恋情。我是说，迈克尔在扮演丘比特。
He is.
Kevin tries to chatter up, but he kind of keeps putting his foot in his mouth.
He does mention the Circle Drive-in.
That's a real place.
looked it up, it's in Scranton, and it's still in operation.
One of my favorites, though, is when Michael tries to set up Meredith.
Mm-hmm.
He says, so, Eric, you mentioned that you are in tool and dye repair.
他是。凯文试图和她聊天，但他有点总是说错话。他确实提到了Circle汽车影院。那是个真实的地方。我查过了，它在斯克兰顿，而且还在运营。不过，我最喜欢的是迈克尔试图撮合梅雷迪思的时候。嗯哼。他说，那么，埃里克，你提到你是做工具和模具维修的。
I loved that.
Yeah.
Do you think he works at Crest's tool and die?
Probably.
It's on the sign down in the lobby.
Yes.
This is like a business park, right?
Yes, exactly.
我喜欢那个。是的。你觉得他在克雷斯特工具和模具公司工作吗？可能吧。大厅的牌子上写着。是的。这就像一个商业园区，对吧？是的，完全正确。
Eric says, I am.
And then Michael says, well, Meredith recently had a total hysterectomy.
So that's sort of a repair.
All right.
I'll let you do.
Talk. Would you like a guest star breakdown on Eric? I would. He was played by Jason Rogel,
and I found a very interesting crossover connection. I know it. Tell us, Angela. Jason and I,
when he played Eric, we didn't know each other, but years later, we would both be in the Netflix movie
埃里克说，我是。然后迈克尔说，嗯，梅雷迪思最近做了全子宫切除术。所以那也算是一种维修。好吧。我让你说。你想听听关于埃里克的客串嘉宾介绍吗？我想听。他由杰森·罗格尔饰演，我发现了一个非常有趣的交叉联系。我知道。告诉我们，安吉拉。杰森和我，当他饰演埃里克时，我们互不相识，但多年后，我们都出演了Netflix的电影
Toll Girl together. Yes. Mm-hmm. So crazy. I know, a little mini office reunion. He played the
doctor, the pediatrician, when Steve's on, who plays my husband and I, we go to meet with the
pediatrician because our daughter is so incredibly tall at such a young age, and he played the pediatrician.
Should we go to the restaurant? We should because Bob and Phyllis have not come back from the bathroom.
No, and Jim and Pam are very hungry. Their food is there. This is getting so awkward.
They're discussing when are you allowed to eat? And Jim says, did you get hot food? And Pam says, no, she got
cold food, and he said, then I think you need to wait. Right. You have to wait for the other people.
And Pam says, Bob got hot food, and I think his fries are getting cold. And then they start
Toll Girl在一起。是的。嗯哼。太疯狂了。我知道，一个小型的办公室重聚。他扮演医生，儿科医生，当史蒂夫和我扮演的夫妻去见儿科医生时，因为我们的女儿在这么小的年纪就长得特别高，他扮演的就是那个儿科医生。我们要去餐厅吗？我们应该去，因为鲍勃和菲利斯还没从洗手间回来。不，而且吉姆和帕姆非常饿。他们的食物就在那儿。这变得太尴尬了。他们在讨论什么时候可以吃东西？吉姆说，你拿到热食了吗？帕姆说，没有，她拿到的是冷食，他说，那我觉得你需要等一下。对。你必须等其他人。帕姆说，鲍勃拿到了热食，我想他的薯条快凉了。然后他们开始
eating his fries. And then they eat his steak. I know. Did you see how I was really eating the steak?
Lady, I was starving. I was, like, so excited to eat the fries and the steak. That was real. That's my
real hunger. I thought it rang pretty true, just knowing you the way I know you when you get hungry.
Yep. That you would not hesitate to take food.
off someone else's plate, especially because they hadn't been on that plate yet.
When I was a caterer, would you take things and nibble?
You know, when I was clearing the tables, if there was like a roll or like part of a chicken
breast that had clearly not been touched, I would eat it.
吃他的薯条。然后他们吃了他的牛排。我知道。你看到我当时是怎么吃牛排的吗？天哪，我饿坏了。我当时对吃薯条和牛排感到非常兴奋。那是真的。那是真实的饥饿感。我觉得这很真实，因为我了解你，知道你饿的时候是什么样。是的。你绝对会毫不犹豫地从别人的盘子里拿食物，尤其是因为他们还没动过那些食物。我做餐饮服务员的时候，你会拿东西吃吗？你知道，当我清理桌子时，如果有一个餐包或者一块明显没被动过的鸡胸肉，我会吃掉它。
I mean, I was hungry and I, you know, was a struggling actor.
It was a free meal.
I sort of piece it together from everybody's plate.
Let me tell you something, Angela, because you brought up food and eating for me.
You know it's important to me. And it's so important to me this idea of like being at a large
dinner party and people are getting served food and when do you get to eat your food that I actually
looked it up once. Like the etiquette of it? Yes. And I read that in a large dinner party,
if they're serving something cold, you have to wait for everybody to get their cold dish,
我的意思是，我很饿，而且你知道，我当时是个挣扎中的演员。那是一顿免费的饭。我会从每个人的盘子里拼凑出一顿饭。让我告诉你一件事，安吉拉，因为你提到了食物和吃东西。你知道这对我很重要。而且这个想法对我来说非常重要，比如在一个大型晚宴上，人们开始上菜，你什么时候可以吃你的食物，我甚至查过这个。比如礼仪方面？是的。我读到在大型晚宴上，如果上的是冷食，你必须等每个人都拿到他们的冷盘，
like a salad or a cold soup before you start eating. But if something hot is being served,
after two or more people have been served that hot dish, you can begin eating while you wait
for the rest of the party to get their dish. And I've stuck with that in my life when I've been
at like, let's say a table of 10. If I get my hot dish, I'm the fourth person to get it. I start
eating it because that's what the book said and because I want to. But I digged a little
deeper.
Okay.
Since we're on the topic of dining etiquette.
比如沙拉或冷汤，然后才能开始吃。但如果上的是热食，在两个人或更多人拿到热菜后，你就可以在等待其他人拿到菜的同时开始吃了。我在生活中一直遵循这一点，比如在10个人的桌子上。如果我拿到了热菜，我是第四个拿到的人。我就开始吃了，因为书上是这么说的，而且我也想吃。但我深入研究了一下。好吧。既然我们在谈论用餐礼仪。
Okay.
Here are some other dining etiquette rules for you.
Apparently, if you get a dinner roll, etiquette says you should only butter one bite at a time.
You shouldn't butter your whole piece of bread.
Get out.
Isn't that crazy?
I'm going to put butter all over it.
I butter the whole thing.
好吧。这里还有一些其他的用餐礼仪规则给你。显然，如果你拿到了餐包，礼仪说你一次只能抹一口的黄油。你不应该把整块面包都抹上黄油。别开玩笑了。我打算把上面全抹上黄油。我把整块都抹上。
I want more butter.
But if you butter it one bite at a time, you might get it.
You're double dipping.
But no, because you're using.
using a special knife.
And you're putting it on your bread and you're taking a bite and then you're doing that
knife on that shared communal butter again.
Etiquette, I don't think you're right.
我想要更多的黄油。但如果你一次抹一口，你可能会吃到。你在重复蘸取。但不，因为你用的是。用一把特殊的刀。你把它抹在面包上，然后咬一口，然后你又用那把刀去蘸那个共享的公共黄油。礼仪，我不认为你是对的。
Well, that's what it said.
Okay.
Also, out of respect for the chef, you should always try several bites of your food before
adding any salt or pepper.
Well, we always say that to our kids.
Like, try it before you salt it, guys.
If someone asks you to pass the salt, do you know you're supposed to pass the salt?
do you know you're supposed to pass the salt and pepper together?
嗯，书上就是这么说的。好吧。另外，出于对厨师的尊重，你应该在加任何盐或胡椒之前先尝几口食物。嗯，我们总是对我们的孩子这么说。比如，在加盐之前先尝尝，孩子们。如果有人让你递盐，你知道你应该递盐吗？你知道你应该把盐和胡椒一起递过去吗？
I do.
They're a pair. They like to travel together.
They travel together.
If you're enjoying a family-style meal, you're supposed to pass the dishes clockwise around the table.
Oh, gosh. At our family, it's like a free-for-all.
Same. Also, this one I found very interesting.
If you leave the table and you're in the middle of a meal, do you know where you're supposed to put your napkin?
To the left of your plate?
我知道。它们是一对。它们喜欢一起旅行。它们一起旅行。如果你在享受家庭式聚餐，你应该顺时针传递盘子。哦，天哪。在我们家，这就像是一场混战。我也是。另外，这个我发现非常有趣。如果你在用餐中途离开桌子，你知道你应该把餐巾放在哪里吗？放在盘子的左边？
That's what I thought. To the side of your meal.
plate. Yeah. Your chair. What? Supposed to set it on your chair. Gross. My butt was just there. Why do I want to put that? What? No. Maybe your hot feet were tucked up under your butt. I know. I could have a hot foot inside out underwear chair. Yeah. That's gross. Why are we talking about my chair?
You brought up all of these things. The hot feet, your underwear, the chair, the chair,
This is all your stuff.
Why are you making me talk about this?
Pam and Jim can't take it anymore.
It's been so long.
They're like, did they ditch us?
我也是这么想的。放在餐盘的旁边。是的。你的椅子。什么？应该放在你的椅子上。恶心。我的屁股刚才就在那儿。我为什么要放那儿？什么？不。也许你发热的脚塞在屁股下面了。我知道。我的椅子上可能有发热的脚和内衣。是的。那太恶心了。我们为什么要谈论我的椅子？是你提起了所有这些事情。发热的脚，你的内衣，椅子，椅子，这都是你的东西。你为什么要让我谈论这个？帕姆和吉姆受不了了。已经过了这么久了。他们想，他们是不是把我们甩了？
Yeah.
Where are they?
Maybe they just left.
Well, they go to look for them over by the restrooms.
Yeah.
And what do they hear moaning behind a door?
It is on.
They are clearly getting it on.
是的。他们在哪里？也许他们只是走了。好吧，他们去洗手间那边找他们。是的。他们听到门后有什么呻吟声？开始了。他们显然是在亲热。
Jim and Pam are horrified.
Then, when they come back to the table, can we talk about Phyllis?
She's so flustered.
She's like sweaty.
Chugging her water.
Phyllis should get an Emmy for that moment.
She's so brilliant.
It's so good.
吉姆和帕姆惊呆了。然后，当他们回到桌子旁时，我们可以谈谈菲利斯吗？她太慌乱了。她满头大汗。大口喝水。菲利斯应该因为那一刻获得艾美奖。她太棒了。太精彩了。
And then at 17 minutes, 35 seconds, can we please talk about the way that Bob Vance holds his fork when he
starts cutting his steak. He's like got his fork in like a fist and he stabbed it into the steak
and he's cutting it. He feeds it to Phyllis. I had a question about this moment. Okay. Yes.
He says, do you want any steak? And she's like, sure. And he passes it over to her. And she says,
no mushrooms. He says, sorry, I forgot. And then she eats the steak. I was like, this is so nuanced.
This feels so personal and intimate. Was this written? And I went to the script and this is
not in the script. The whole steak thing isn't? Him feeding her in the mushroom. Wow. That's crazy
because I just remember shooting it several times. So it must have been an on the day thing because it wasn't a
然后在17分35秒，我们可以谈谈鲍勃·万斯开始切牛排时拿叉子的方式吗？他像握拳一样握着叉子，把它插进牛排里，然后切开。他喂给菲利斯吃。我有一个关于这个时刻的问题。好吧。是的。他说，你想吃牛排吗？她说，当然。他递给她。她说，不要蘑菇。他说，抱歉，我忘了。然后她吃了牛排。我觉得这太细腻了。这感觉非常个人化和亲密。这是写好的吗？我看了剧本，剧本里没有这一段。整个牛排的事都没有？他喂她吃蘑菇。哇。这太疯狂了，因为我记得拍了好几次。所以这一定是当场发挥的，因为它不是
one-time improv. Right. Because they had to set up that camera specifically to get that look from me and John.
Right. And I remember that we had a hard time holding it. Because it was very funny. But my question is,
was the mushroom thing an accident? I don't remember. When he stabs the steak and maybe in real life,
Phyllis doesn't like mushrooms.
Maybe not.
So she just improv.
No mushrooms.
I don't know.
一次性的即兴表演。对。因为他们必须专门设置那个摄像机来捕捉我和约翰的那个表情。对。我记得我们很难忍住不笑。因为太搞笑了。但我的问题是，蘑菇的事是意外吗？我不记得了。当他插牛排时，也许在现实生活中，菲利斯不喜欢蘑菇。也许不是。所以她只是即兴发挥。不要蘑菇。我不知道。
It's so specific.
It's so good.
I loved it.
Back at the mixer, Michael keeps looking at the door.
He's really hoping Glove Girl will show up.
And Dwight is like, why do you keep looking at the front door?
Someone after you?
Okay, wait.
太具体了。太棒了。我喜欢它。回到聚会上，迈克尔一直盯着门口。他真的希望手套女孩会出现。德怀特说，你为什么一直盯着前门看？有人在追你吗？好吧，等等。
We got a fan question about that from Amy P.
She says, when Dwight asks Michael if someone's after him and Oscar says,
Why do you always go to that?
Has anyone ever been after anyone in this office?
Amy says, um, yes, Oscar.
Roy!
Yes, remember Roy?
He was definitely after Jim and Dwight saved the day.
我们收到了艾米·P发来的粉丝提问。她说，当德怀特问迈克尔是否有人在追他，而奥斯卡说，你为什么总是往那方面想？办公室里有人被追过吗？艾米说，嗯，是的，奥斯卡。罗伊！是的，记得罗伊吗？他绝对是在追吉姆，而德怀特拯救了局面。
Listen, Dwight is ready with weaponry all the time.
There is a moment where a woman shows up who is not Michael's lady.
Mm-hmm.
And he turns her away.
Everyone groans.
I don't know that he turns her away, but she walks in
and everyone is so excited for Glove Girl
that when Michael's like, nope, they're like,
听着，德怀特随时准备着武器。有一个时刻，一个不是迈克尔女士的女人出现了。嗯哼。他把她打发走了。每个人都发出呻吟。我不知道他是不是把她打发走了，但她走进来，每个人都对手套女孩感到非常兴奋，所以当迈克尔说，不，他们就像，
and she leaves.
Yeah.
This unnamed woman.
I looked her up.
Do you know who she is?
Oh, I do.
Dorian Frankel.
Uh-huh.
然后她就走了。是的。这个无名女子。我查了她。你知道她是谁吗？哦，我知道。多里安·弗兰克尔。嗯哼。
She was Allison Jones casting associate
for the office after Phyllis left.
Let me tell you a little bit about Dorian.
I met her a lifetime ago.
Dorian, if you're hearing this.
Hi, it was so fun to see your face.
We did improv together at Improv Olympic.
also known as IOS. We were on a long-form team called, ready for this, fluffers.
她是《办公室》在菲利斯离开后的艾莉森·琼斯选角助理。让我告诉你一点关于多里安的事。我很久以前就认识她了。多里安，如果你在听这个。嗨，见到你的脸真有趣。我们在即兴奥林匹克一起做过即兴表演。也称为IOS。我们在一个名为“Fluffers”的长篇团队里，准备好了吗？
Oh. Dorian, do you remember this if you hear this? We were on a team called Fluffers. We would
rehearse in her apartment. And she was lovely. And I'm so happy for her. She recently won an Emmy
for casting Veep. Yes. So she's amazing. Dorian, oh my gosh, flash from the past.
So that was my other crossover connection with a guest star in this episode.
Amazing. Dwight has kind of zeroed in on Rie, woman who is dressed like Angela, but not for the reasons we think.
Well, he finds out when they're talking that she works at a place that does catalogs for community colleges and small businesses.
They must use a lot of paper.
I mean, at first we're like, is he attracted to her? No, he's just trying to make a huge paper sale.
哦。多里安，如果你听到这个，你还记得吗？我们在一个叫“Fluffers”的团队。我们会在她的公寓里排练。她很可爱。我为她感到高兴。她最近凭借《副总统》的选角获得了艾美奖。是的。所以她很棒。多里安，天哪，往事重现。所以这是我在这一集中与客串明星的另一个交叉联系。太棒了。德怀特有点盯上了瑞，一个打扮得像安吉拉的女人，但不是因为我们想的原因。好吧，当他们交谈时，他发现她在一家为社区学院和小企业制作目录的地方工作。他们一定用了大量的纸。我的意思是，起初我们想，他被她吸引了吗？不，他只是想做一笔巨大的纸张交易。
Yes.
Jenna, there was a lot in deleted scenes of like people just sort of chit-chatting, trying to flirt.
trying to meet people, make conversation.
Well, Creed talks to Lynn.
Oh!
He tries to strike up conversation with her.
You got to hear it.
How old are you?
是的。珍娜，删除的场景里有很多人们只是在闲聊，试图调情。试图结识人，进行交谈。好吧，克里德和琳谈话。哦！他试图和她搭讪。你得听听。你多大了？
Wait?
Let me guess.
30.
No, no, no.
60.
34.
Cool beans.
Me too.
等等？让我猜猜。30岁。不，不，不。60岁。34岁。酷毙了。我也是。
Well, you were you born?
Wow.
I know.
First of all, he leads off with, like, how old are you?
Let me guess.
And then he goes from 30 to 60.
This is Creed trying to make small talk guys.
I remember I was in a bar once and a guy tried to flirt with me by asking me how much I weighed.
好吧，你出生在哪里？哇。我知道。首先，他以“你多大了？让我猜猜”开头。然后他从30岁猜到60岁。这就是克里德试图进行闲聊，伙计们。我记得我曾经在酒吧里，一个男人试图通过问我体重来和我调情。
And then he said, I bet I can guess.
And then he picked me up without my consent and then set a number.
Fellas, there's so much wrong with this.
I hope we don't have to break it down for you.
But like, don't do that.
Yeah.
All those things.
然后他说，我打赌我能猜到。然后他在未经我同意的情况下把我抱了起来，然后说了一个数字。伙计们，这有很多不对劲的地方。我希望我们不必为你拆解它。但是，别那样做。是的。所有这些事情。是的。
Don't say as your pickup line, let me guess your age or your weight.
Yeah.
Don't put your hands on a lady unless she invites you to.
So many things.
But you know who did spark some interest in Lynn?
Ultimately was Kevin.
I know.
不要把“让我猜猜你的年龄或体重”作为你的搭讪台词。是的。除非女士邀请你，否则不要把手放在她身上。太多事情了。太多事情了。但你知道谁确实引起了琳的兴趣吗？最终是凯文。我知道。
And he's very charming in his just nervousness and honesty.
And doesn't Brian kill it.
in the scene where he shows that she gave him her business card.
Yes.
It reminds me of that episode when they won their parking lot back from the five families.
And he's like, sometimes you just need things to go your way.
Yes. I mean, I'm getting goosebumps just thinking about it when he does that.
Such a good actor.
他在他的紧张和诚实中非常有魅力。布莱恩在那个场景中表现得太棒了，他展示了她给了他名片。是的。这让我想起了他们从五大家族手中赢回停车场的那一集。他说，有时候你只需要事情按你的方式发展。是的。我的意思是，想到他那样做，我都会起鸡皮疙瘩。真是个好演员。
I know.
Unfortunately, it looks like they're going to have to close down the party and
Glove Girl never shows up.
Michael doesn't want to leave.
He wants to keep waiting it out.
And people stick around for a while.
It's very sweet.
Even Angela.
我知道。不幸的是，看起来他们不得不结束聚会，而手套女孩从未出现。迈克尔不想离开。他想继续等下去。人们待了一会儿。这很贴心。甚至安吉拉也是。
Even Stanley.
Yeah.
And Oscar's ultimately like, no, come on, Michael.
It's time.
Let's all walk out together.
We got mail.
Okay.
甚至斯坦利也是。是的。是的。奥斯卡最终说，不，来吧，迈克尔。是时候了。让我们一起走出去。我们有邮件。好吧。
Aiden M.
wrote in to say,
Why did Michael never get to find the lady who left her glove in the blood drive?
It has driven me crazy, even though he ends up with Holly.
And Diana P. went on to say, why didn't this storyline continue?
I asked Katie about it because I was curious.
It just shows you how good of a job they did together in that scene that people wanted to see more of the blood drive girl and Michael.
Well, the message boards after this episode aired were all for Love Girl.
艾登·M写信说，为什么迈克尔从来没有找到那个在献血活动中留下手套的女士？这让我快疯了，尽管他最终和霍莉在一起了。戴安娜·P接着说，为什么这个故事情节没有继续？我问了凯蒂，因为我很好奇。这只是说明他们在那个场景中做得有多好，人们想看到更多关于献血女孩和迈克尔的故事。好吧，这一集播出后的留言板上全是关于手套女孩的。
And here's what Katie had to say.
Oh, man, you guys.
So here is the thing about my experience is that when I auditioned,
it was with the caveat that it was a possible recurring character.
And so all I wanted was to perform well and to impress.
and to be asked back.
And it didn't happen.
It didn't happen.
这就是凯蒂要说的。哦，天哪，伙计们。关于我的经历是这样的，当我试镜时，前提是这是一个可能的常驻角色。所以我想要的只是表现出色，给人留下深刻印象。并被要求回来。但这没有发生。没有发生。
And I'm sure they had their creative reasons.
But, oh boy, I wanted nothing more.
But I'm happy with the time I got.
That's for sure.
So, I will tell you, story-wise, why Glove Girl did not come back.
It was not because we were not completely charmed.
by Katie and her performance.
No, she crushed it.
我相信他们有他们的创作原因。但是，天哪，我什么都不想要，只想要那个机会。但我对得到的时光感到满意。那是肯定的。所以，我会告诉你，从故事的角度来看，为什么手套女孩没有回来。并不是因为我们没有被凯蒂和她的表演完全迷住。不，她表现得太棒了。
Clearly, yes.
Michael has a talking head, and it's really written in this talking head.
He says that this is the first time since Holly that he's even considered getting back into the dating marina.
Marina?
The marina.
Like Cupid Sparrow.
Yeah.
And that was the story point of this episode, was not.
显然，是的。迈克尔有一个独白，这个独白里确实写了。他说这是自霍莉以来，他第一次考虑重返约会市场。市场？码头。就像丘比特的麻雀。是的。这一集的故事点不是。
to introduce a new love interest for Michael. They ultimately decided. They were toying with this idea.
But really, it was just for Michael to feel like he could connect with someone again. But ultimately,
they're going to keep him on this trajectory toward Holly. But because of this storyline, he's not
going to be kind of as broken when he does finally reunite with her. Does that make sense?
Yeah. No, he's hopeful. He's getting a little bit of his comments.
confidence back. Yes. And that's important. Yeah. Well, the whole gang is going to leave the building.
And Jenna, I just want you guys to know, when you watch us all exit, Mindy and I are just having a
conversation. Yeah, I saw that. I'm gesturing to my hair. I don't know what we're talking about.
为了给迈克尔介绍一个新的恋爱对象。他们最终决定了。他们一直在玩弄这个想法。但实际上，这只是为了让迈克尔觉得他可以再次与人建立联系。但最终，他们会让他保持在这个通往霍莉的轨道上。但因为这个故事情节，当他最终与她重聚时，他不会那么破碎。这有意义吗？是的。不，他充满希望。他正在找回一点自信。是的。这很重要。是的。好吧，整帮人都要离开大楼了。珍娜，我只是想让你们知道，当你们看着我们所有人离开时，明迪和我只是在交谈。是的，我看到了。我在比划我的头发。我不知道我们在谈论什么。
I don't either. You're very animated. Very animated. And then I feel like they sort of let us know that we're on
camera because then I'd go back to Angela Martin and I do these little awkward waves goodbye. But everyone is very
pleasant and nice to one another.
Michael's Lonely Hearts party was kind of a success.
Yeah.
I mean, they were all sort of lonely together.
This episode ends with a great tag.
我也不知道。你非常生动。非常生动。然后我觉得他们让我们知道我们在镜头前，因为然后我回到安吉拉·马丁的角色，我做了这些尴尬的挥手告别。但每个人对彼此都非常愉快和友善。迈克尔的孤独之心派对算是一种成功。是的。我的意思是，他们都在一起孤独。是的。这一集以一个很棒的尾声结束。
That's so funny.
Found it very funny.
Stanley goes into the Pledmobile, and he's got a little bandage on his arm.
He's got a cotton ball with a little bit of medical tape.
And he says, I'm so sorry, I gave blood earlier, and I'm still feeling a little woozy.
Do you have a cookie?
Can I have one of those cookies?
Right.
太搞笑了。觉得非常有趣。斯坦利走进献血车，他的手臂上贴着一个小绷带。他有一个棉球和一点医用胶带。他说，我很抱歉，我早些时候献了血，现在还是觉得有点头晕。你有饼干吗？我可以吃那些饼干吗？对。
And she says, you know what?
You have a cotton ball in medical tape, but we're using band-aids.
Yeah, she's like, huh.
Weird.
And behind him, Phyllis walks up.
He's making a quick exit, and he just goes, band-aid.
And she's like, damn it.
And then Creed leaves the truck with his blood in a bag or someone else's.
她说，你知道吗？你有一个棉球和医用胶带，但我们用的是创可贴。是的，她就像，嗯。奇怪。在他身后，菲利斯走了上来。他正匆忙离开，他只是说，创可贴。她说，该死。然后克里德带着他的血袋或者别人的血袋离开了卡车。
I'm not sure.
To go where?
To do what?
I don't know.
But this is what Dwight has been worried about the whole episode.
I know.
Where is Dwight?
I don't know.
我不确定。去哪儿？做什么？我不知道。但这正是德怀特整集都在担心的事。我知道。德怀特在哪里？我不知道。
Well, that was Blood Drive, everybody.
That is Blood Drive, everyone.
I'm going to go home.
I'm going to put on different shoes.
Cool off your feet.
Don't put on any shoes.
Just take shoes off.
It's like 95 degrees out.
好吧，这就是《献血》，大家。这就是《献血》，每个人。我要回家了。我要换双鞋。给你的脚降降温。不要穿任何鞋子。把鞋脱了就行。外面大概有95度。
I encourage you to get a pair of flip-flops.
Yeah, and I guess I have to fix my hair.
Well, you do have one guy that's going,
he's like at attention.
just in your bangs.
I'm growing my bangs out.
Oh, it's a transition.
They're a strange length.
我建议你买一双人字拖。是的，我想我得整理一下我的头发。好吧，你确实有一个家伙在看着，他就像在立正。只是在你的刘海里。我正在留长刘海。哦，这是一个过渡期。它们的长度很奇怪。
It was a summer thing.
We're moving into fall.
Yeah, you got to have your fall hairdo.
That's right.
I'm moving into, I don't know what my fall hairdo is yet,
but we're transitioning out of bangs right now.
I can't wait to see what your fall hairdo is.
Well, I know I'm going to get the truth from you.
这是一个夏天的东西。我们正在进入秋天。是的，你得有你的秋季发型。没错。我正在进入，我还不知道我的秋季发型是什么，但我们现在正在从刘海过渡出来。我迫不及待地想看看你的秋季发型是什么。好吧，我知道我会从你那里得到真相。
That's for sure.
All right, everybody's week.
I love you, lady.
All right, guys, have a great week.
We'll see you later.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink.
This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf.
那是肯定的。那是肯定的。好吧，大家的周。我爱你，女士。好吧，伙计们，祝你们有愉快的一周。我们回头见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
Our Second Drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent.
Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratt.
You know,
《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的“第二杯”剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特的《Rubber Tree》。你知道，